>> GREAT.
LET ME FIRST SAY GOOD MORNING
AND WELCOME.
TODAY'S OVERSIGHT HEARING IS
INTENDED TO PROVIDE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE, AS
WELL AS THE PUBLIC,
WITH AN UPDATE FROM THE STATE'S
ENERGY AGENCIES
AND THE STATE'S PRINCIPAL
ELECTRICAL GRID OPERATOR,
ON THE EFFORTS TO ADDRESS
ELECTRICITY RELIABILITY
ASSOCIATED WITH MANAGING SUPPLY
AND DEMAND,
PARTICULARLY GIVEN EXTREME
WEATHER EVENTS AND AS
THE STATE TRANSITIONS TO ZERO
CARBON ENERGY.
FUTURE.
THIS IS A FOLLOW UP TO LAST
YEAR'S, UH,
SIMILARLY FOCUSED OVERSIGHT
HEARING,
AS WELL AS OVERSIGHT HEARING
PREVIOUSLY
HELD IN RECENT YEARS,
INCLUDING IN 2021, IN RESPONSE
TO
THE AUGUST 2020 UNEXPECTED
ELECTRICITY
ROTATING OUTAGES ORDERED BY THE
STATE'S
MAIN ELECTRICAL GRID OPERATOR,
THE CALIFORNIA INDEPENDENT
SYSTEMS
OPERATOR, OR CAL, ISO,
AND A HEARING IN 2022 REGARDING
THE PROPOSED EXTENSION OF
THE OPERATIONS OF DIABLO CANYON
NUCLEAR POWER PLANT,
IN LARGE PART TO SUPPORT OUR
ELECTRICITY
SUPPLY RELIABILITY,
WHICH WE'VE PROVEN TO BE VERY
CRITICAL
AND NEEDED AT THIS TIME.
SINCE 2020, WE HAVE EXPERIENCED
CHALLENGES TO ENSURING
RELIABILITY DURING SOME EXTREME
HEAT EVENTS,
PARTICULARLY IN THE EVENING
HOURS
IN THE LATE SUMMER MONTHS
WHEN RESIDENTS RELY ON AIR
CONDITIONING TO KEEP COOL.
LAST YEAR, THE ISO ISSUED
EMERGENCY ALERTS
EARLIER IN THE SUMMER SO FAR
THIS SUMMER,
THERE HAVE NOT BEEN ANY
EMERGENCY
ALERTS ISSUED BY THE CAL ISO.
HOWEVER, LAST MONTH, THE ISO
ISSUED
SEVERAL DAYS OF NOTICES FOR
TRANSMISSION EMERGENCIES AND
RESTRICTED
MAINTENANCE OPERATIONS.
THOSE SEEMINGLY MANAGED THESE
NOTICES
SERVE AS A REMINDER OF THE
IMPORTANCE
OF THE NEED TO REMAIN VIGILANT
AND ON
RELIABILITY OF THE ELECTRIC
GRID.
WE KNOW THAT ELECTRICITY
OUTAGES,
DEPENDING ON THEIR SCALE,
DURATION AND FREQUENCY, CAN BE
LIFE THREATENING.
ELECTRICITY OUTAGES CAN BE
CAUSED BY
MANY ISSUES INCLUDED
DISTRIBUTION,
EQUIPMENT FAILURE, OR AS A
SAFETY
MEASURE SUCH AS PUBLIC SAFETY.
POWER SHUT OFFS WHEN WILDFIRE
RISKS ARE HIGH.
TODAY'S HEARING IS FOCUSED ON
THE SUPPLY AND DEMAND
CHALLENGES OF BALANCING THE
ELECTRIC GRID.
THE CHALLENGES TO ENSURING
RELIABILITY ARE SEVERAL
AS TRANSITION TO ZERO CARBON
FUTURE,
INCLUDING A NEW MIX OF
GENERATION RESOURCES
SUPPLYING ELECTRICITY TO THE
ELECTRIC GRID,
INCLUDING A SIGNIFICANT PORTION
THAT ARE VARIABLE,
SUCH AS WIND AND SOLAR,
WHICH ARE NOT AVAILABLE AT ALL
TIMES,
INCLUDING DURING PEAK HOURS.
THE DEPLOYMENT OF DISTRIBUTED
ENERGY RESOURCES
CAN HELP REDUCE THE DEMANDS ON
ELECTRIC GRID,
BUT CAN ALSO CONTRIBUTE TO
THE PEAK DEMAND AS THE ENERGY
FROM
DISTRIBUTED ENERGY RESOURCES
MAY NO LONGER BE GENERATING,
AND THESE CUSTOMERS MUST RELY ON
THE ELECTRIC GRID,
FOR EXAMPLE, ROOFTOP SOLAR
WITHOUT BATTERY BACKUP.
LOCAL AND STATE POLICIES TO
MITIGATE
CLIMATE EMISSIONS ARE
DRIVING INCREASING ELECTRICITY
DEMAND, QUITE LITERALLY,
AS THE TRANSPORTATION AND
BUILDING SECTORS
ARE INCREASINGLY REQUIRED TO
SHIFT
AWAY FROM FOSSIL FUELS TO
CLEANER CARBON SOURCES,
ESPECIALLY ELECTRICITY.
THE GROWING DEVELOPMENT OF
ARTIFICIAL
INTELLIGENCE IS FURTHER
INCREASING
ELECTRICITY DEMANDS NEEDED TO
OPERATE COMPUTING SYSTEMS.
STATE POLICIES THAT AUTHORIZE
LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS WHO ELECT AND,
IN MORE LIMITED CASES, PRIVATE
COMPANIES.
THE ABILITY TO PROCURE
ELECTRICITY RESOURCES
KNOWN AS A COMMUNITY CHOICE
AGGREGATORS OR CCAS AND ELECTRIC
SERVICE PROVIDERS RESPECTIVELY,
RESULTING IN A FRAGMENTED
PROCUREMENT
LANDSCAPE THAT ADDS
COMPLICATIONS TOWARDS A SEAMLESS
TRANSITION TO MEETING
THE STATE'S RENEWABLE ENERGY
AND ZERO
CARBON ENERGY RESOURCES GOAL,
WHILE ENSURING ELECTRICITY
RELIABILITY.
ADDITIONALLY, THE CURRENT
TIGHTENING
OF RESOURCES ADEQUACY OR
RESOURCE
ADEQUACY MARKET WOULD
REQUIREMENTS
FOR PLANNING RESERVE MARGINS,
INCREASING THE STATE PROCUREMENT
RESOURCES TO SERVE AS INSURANCE,
AND LIMITED IMPORTS,
PARTICULARLY
THE LIMITED OUT OF STATE
HYDROPOWER
RESOURCES DUE TO DROUGHT
CONDITIONS
IN THE NORTH WEST AND CANADA,
SEEM TO BE FURTHER INCREASING
PRICES FOR ALL CUSTOMERS.
AS I'VE SAID BEFORE,
WE'RE FLYING AN AIRPLANE WHILE
REDESIGNING IT,
ADDING PASSENGERS AND CHANGING
THE FUEL MIX MID-AIR
AS WEATHER FORECASTS CONSTANTLY
SHIFT,
REQUIRING ADJUSTMENTS TO THE
FLIGHT PATHS.
IN RECENT YEARS, WE HAVE
APPROPRIATED
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
OF STATE BUDGET TOWARD
ELECTRICITY RELIABILITY,
AUTHORIZED EXTENSION OF DIABLO
CANYON NUCLEAR POWER PLANT,
AND JUST LAST YEAR AUTHORIZED
THE DEPARTMENT OF WATER
RESOURCES TO SERVE AS A CENTRAL
PROCUREMENT
ENTITY SHOULD THE PUC IDENTIFY
A NEED
FOR A SPECIFIED LONG TIME
RESOURCES.
WHEN WE ARE IN OUR EFFORTS TO
ENSURE, I MEAN,
WHERE ARE WE IN OUR EFFORTS TO
ENSURE RELIABILITY?
WHAT'S OUR GAME PLAN TO ENSURE
THAT RELIABILITY
REMAINS AT THE FOREFRONT OF OUR
EFFORTS?
AND EVEN AS WE TRANSITION TO
ZERO ENERGY
AND WORK TOWARD ENSURING
AFFORDABILITY?
ADDITIONALLY, I'VE ASKED THE
ADMINISTRATION
TO PROVIDE A BRIEF
SUMMARY UPDATE OF THE WEST WIDE
PATHWAYS INITIATIVE,
AN EFFORT TO EXPAND ENERGY
MARKETS ACROSS THE WEST
CURRENTLY WITHIN THE LIMITS OF
EXISTING LAW.
THE INTENT IS TO PROVIDE MEMBERS
WITH AN AWARENESS
AND UNDERSTANDING OF THE EFFORT,
THOUGH ADDITIONAL DISCUSSIONS
AND BRIEFINGS MAY BE NEEDED.
WITH ALL THAT BEING SAID,
NOW LET'S HEAR FROM OUR ENERGY
AGENCIES,
THE CALIFORNIA ENERGY
COMMISSION,
THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC UTILITIES
AS WELL AS THE DEPARTMENT OF
WATER RESOURCES
AND THE CALIFORNIA INDEPENDENT
SYSTEM OPERATOR.
I WANT TO SAY WELCOME, AND WE
WILL BEGIN WITH
OUR CALIFORNIA ENERGY VICE
CHAIR, MR.
GUNDA.
AND WE ASK THAT YOU COME FORWARD
AND WHEN YOU'RE READY,
YOU MAY BEGIN YOUR PRESENTATION.
MR.
CHAIR.
YES, SIR.
ARE THESE THE.
>> PILOTS OF THAT AIRPLANE?
>> GOOD MORNING.
MR..
THAT'S RIGHT.
ARE YOU READY?
>> GOOD MORNING, CHAIR BRADFORD
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
I'M PLEASED TO BE HERE WITH
YOU TODAY
TO DISCUSS ELECTRICITY SYSTEM
RELIABILITY WITH MY COLLEAGUES
FROM THE ENERGY COMMISSION,
THE CALIFORNIA INDEPENDENT
SYSTEM OPERATOR
IN THE DEPARTMENT OF WATER
RESOURCES.
I'M GOING TO START US OFF,
AND THEN WE WILL ALL BE SHARING
THE EXPLANATION
OF A POWERPOINT PRESENTATION
THAT WE HAVE FOR YOU TODAY.
UM, WE'RE HERE TO TALK ABOUT
SUMMER
RELIABILITY READINESS,
BUT I WANT TO START WITH THE
BIG PICTURE,
TO PROVIDE SOME BACKGROUND TO
DESCRIBE
THE BACKGROUND IN WHICH WE'RE
WORKING.
THE ELECTRIC SECTOR PLAYS A
CRITICAL ROLE
IN CALIFORNIA'S CLIMATE CHANGE
STRATEGY.
WE'RE BOTH ELECTRIFYING THE
ECONOMY
AND DECARBONIZING THE SOURCES
OF GENERATION
TO SUPPLY ELECTRICITY FOR THE
THE NEW TYPES OF FUEL SWITCHING.
AND WE'RE THAT WE'RE DOING
THROUGHOUT OUR ECONOMY,
INCLUDING TRANSPORTATION,
ELECTRIFICATION AND BUILDING
ELECTRIFICATION.
MUCH PROGRESS HAS BEEN MADE IN
THE ELECTRIC SECTOR,
AND IN 2022,
61% OF THE STATE'S ELECTRICITY
WAS GENERATED
BY RENEWABLE AND ZERO EMISSION
RESOURCES.
WE ALSO ACHIEVED NEW RECORDS.
JUST THIS YEAR, WE HAD 146 DAYS
WHERE CLEAN
ENERGY EXCEEDED KAIZO CONSUMER
DEMAND.
AT SOME POINT IN THE DAY, WE HAD
AN ALL TIME RECORD
IN SOLAR PRODUCTION PEAK WITH
19,368MW
ON JUNE 20TH AND THE KYSOW
FOOTPRINT IS APPROACHING
TEN GIGAWATTS OF GRID SCALE
BATTERY CAPACITY.
SO WITH THIS MOMENTUM, WE'RE
WORKING TOWARDS
THE GOALS SET BY THE LEGISLATURE
90% CLEAN ELECTRICITY SALES
BY 2035,
95% BY 2040, AND 100% BY 2045.
AT THE SAME TIME, WE'RE, OF
COURSE,
FIGHTING AGAINST THE IMPACTS OF
CLIMATE CHANGE.
CLIMATE CHANGE IS CAUSING
UNPRECEDENTED
STRESS ON OUR GRID.
EXTREME HEAT, DROUGHT,
FLOOD AND WILDFIRES ARE
INCREASING
IN FREQUENCY AND INTENSITY AND
THREATEN RELIABILITY.
THE FUTURE WHAT WE'RE ALL
WORKING TOWARDS
IS ONE THAT THAT IS CLEAN,
SAFE, AFFORDABLE AND RELIABLE,
AND WITH CLEAR STATUTORY
DIRECTIVES AND RELATIVELY
LOW COST OPTIONS FOR CLEAN
ENERGY SUPPLY.
IT'S NOT A QUESTION OF IF, BUT
WHEN,
BUT HOW WE TRANSITION TO OUR
CLEAN ENERGY FUTURE.
I'LL NOW TURN TO VICE CHAIR
GUNDA.
>> THANK YOU, PRESIDENT
REYNOLDS,
AND GOOD MORNING, CHAIR,
AND GOOD MORNING, MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE.
I'M GOING TO GO THROUGH THE NEXT
SEVERAL SLIDES
ON JUST PROVIDING A QUICK UPDATE
ON
BOTH HOW WE DO THE RELIABILITY
PLANNING
AND BUT SOME OF THE NUMBERS WE
HAVE TODAY.
SO THIS SLIDE IS TYPICALLY
ANIMATED.
BUT I KNOW YOU PROBABLY HAVE
JUST
AS A COPY BUT BUT LET ME KIND OF
SITUATE YOU IN THE LAYERED
APPROACH
ON HOW WE DO THE PLANNING.
SO WE HAVE ABOUT FOUR TIME
HORIZONS THAT WE ARE
PLANNING FOR RELIABILITY AND
RESOURCES OVERALL.
SO IT STARTS WITH OUR
OVERARCHING CLIMATE GOALS,
WHICH IS IN THE 10 TO 25 YEAR
TIME FRAME.
SO WE'RE LOOKING ALL THE WAY
TO 2045
THROUGH THE SB 100 PROCESS.
SO HERE WE GET, YOU KNOW,
THE DEMAND ASSUMPTIONS THAT WE
PUT IN ARE
GENERALLY HAVE A LOT OF
UNCERTAINTY.
THEY'RE MORE SCENARIOS NOT
FORECASTS.
THEY INCLUDE A VARIETY OF
SCENARIOS
ON THE ELECTRIFICATION
POTENTIAL DEMAND FLEXIBILITY
AND SUCH.
AND SO ONCE WE DO THAT,
WE HAVE A KIND OF A DIRECTIONAL
INSIGHT INTO THE RESOURCE BUILD
AT THIS POINT.
AND IT'S REALLY NOT LOOKING AT
A PROCUREMENT LEVEL ANALYSIS,
BUT IT'S GIVING US A HIGH LEVEL
VIEW INTO WHAT WE
MIGHT HAVE TO BUILD IN THAT 20
YEAR HORIZON.
THEN IT FOLLOWS WITH THE IRP
STUDIES.
THAT'S THAT'S THE SECOND TIME
FRAME,
WHICH IS THE TEN YEAR TIME
FRAME.
HERE.
THE DEMAND SCENARIOS ARE
REPLACED
MORE WITH DEMAND FORECASTS.
WE HAVE A LITTLE BIT BETTER IDEA
ON WHERE
WE ARE GOING IN THE NEXT TEN
YEARS,
AND WE ENHANCE THE RELIABILITY
STUDIES USING MORE THE STATE,
THE INDUSTRY STANDARDS SUCH AS
THE LOSS OF LOAD EXPECTATION.
THIS IS WHERE YOU'RE BEGINNING
TO
KIND OF HAVE A MUCH BETTER
SENSE.
AND THIS REALLY DRIVES THE
PROCUREMENT.
AND THEN WITHIN THE YEAR TO
THREE YEARS AHEAD,
THIS IS WHERE WE HAVE THE MOST
CERTAINTY ON THE FORECASTS.
AGAIN THOSE FORECASTS COULD BE
WRONG BASED
ON THE LAST COUPLE OF UPS AND
DOWNS,
BUT THIS IS THE BEST, UM, UH,
KIND OF DEMAND IDEA WE HAVE IN
TERMS OF FORECAST AND RESOURCE
ADEQUACY IS THE PROCESS WHERE
YOU'RE SAYING,
I HAVE THIS MUCH PROCUREMENT
THAT
I'VE ALREADY AUTHORIZED.
HOW MUCH OF THAT SHOULD I MAKE
SURE SHOWS
UP IN THE MARKETPLACE IN ANY
GIVEN DAY?
AND THAT'S, YOU KNOW, REALLY
DONE THROUGH THE PUC
AND THIS PROCESS IS GENERALLY
FOLLOWED BY EVERY LRA,
INCLUDING SOME OF THE PWS, LARGE
PWS.
AND THEN FINALLY WE'RE IN
THE OPERATIONAL TIME FRAME.
AND THIS IS WHERE WE REALLY
DIFFER TO KAISO.
YOU KNOW, WE'VE PLANNED WHAT WE
COULD PLAN.
WE KNOW HOW MUCH THE FORECAST
MIGHT BE.
WE HAVE ENSURED THROUGH OUR
THAT WE HAVE THE RESOURCES.
AND NOW WE ARE REALLY TRYING TO
MANAGE THAT IN THE REAL TIME.
SO GOING TO THE NEXT SLIDE.
SO WHAT WE'LL SHOW YOU THEN FOR
TOP LINES
FOR 2020 FOR A KIND OF A
CONTINUED
GROWTH IN OUR RESOURCE ADDITIONS
TO THE OVERARCHING SYSTEM.
SO AS YOU ALL MIGHT NOTE OVER
THE LAST,
YOU KNOW, FOUR YEARS, YOU KNOW,
WE HAVE ADDED ABOUT 20,000MW OF
NEW RESOURCES,
WHICH WE'LL TALK IN A LITTLE
BIT.
BUT GIVEN THAT WE HAVE ADDED
MORE RESOURCES
AND THE DEMAND HAS NOT GROWN AT
THAT LEVEL,
WE DON'T ANTICIPATE ANY
SHORTFALLS UNDER
STANDARD PLANNING CONDITIONS.
THIS IS LOOKING AT THE 17%
PLANNING
RESERVE MARGIN PARADIGM.
WE DON'T SEE ANY SHORTFALLS
UNDER THAT.
EVEN IF THERE IS A 2020 OR A
2022 EQUIVALENT EVENT,
WE STILL DON'T SEE ANY
SHORTFALLS.
THAT DOESN'T MEAN THAT WE ARE
NOT GOING
TO HAVE A LOT OF, UM, UH,
PLANNING,
ACTIVE PLANNING, WEATHER
TRIGGERING
CONTINGENCIES OR SUCH.
WE HAVE THE RESOURCES THAT WE
THINK WE HAVE
AS MATTERS TO THE STEEL IN THE
GROUND,
BUT WE STILL HAVE TO GO THROUGH
THE PROCESS
OF MAKING SURE WE RELY ON THEM.
SO AGAIN, SETTING THE STAGE
WHILE WE HAVE
THE RESOURCES IN ARE BASED ON
THE DEMAND,
A LONG LASTING WEST WIDE HEAT
WAVE OR A HUGE,
HUGE FIRE THAT'S COINCIDENTAL
COULD
STILL STRESS OUR GRID A LOT.
AND I THINK THAT'S SOMETHING
THAT
WE ARE ACTIVELY PREPARING FOR.
ANOTHER ELEMENT THAT GIVES US
SOME, UM,
CONFIDENCE IS REALLY HAVING THE
STRATEGIC RESERVE.
AGAIN, THANKS TO THE
LEGISLATURE, UM,
FOR THE TOOLS THAT WERE PROVIDED
TO THE STATE AGENCIES TO DEVELOP
THE STRATEGIC RESERVE.
WE CURRENTLY HAVE ABOUT 4300MW
IN TOTALITY
OF WHAT WE CALL CONTINGENCY
RESOURCES.
THESE ARE BEYOND THE RESOURCES,
RESOURCE ADEQUACY RESOURCES.
THESE ARE RESOURCES THAT ARE
EITHER
THROUGH THE STRATEGIC RESERVE,
WHICH DELFIN FROM DWR WILL TALK
ABOUT TODAY,
BUT ALSO OTHER TOOLS LIKE THE
DEMAND SIDE
GRID DEMAND SIDE GRID SUPPORT
PROGRAM,
DSGS AND OTHER PROGRAMS WHERE
WE CAN
LEAN ON TO PROVIDE SOME SUPPORT
TO
THE GRID SO OVERALL ADDITIONAL
CONTINGENCIES
WILL LIKELY BE NEEDED.
THE STRATEGIC RESERVE TO REPLACE
OTC GENERATIONS
AS WE MOVE FORWARD IN TIME.
SO JUST KIND OF THEN SITUATING
OURSELVES
IN THE PAST FOUR YEARS,
REAL QUICK REMINDER AS WE THINK
ABOUT
THE CHANGING GRID CONDITIONS,
YOU KNOW,
WE WERE HERE IN FRONT OF YOU
RIGHT
AFTER THE 2020, UM, YOU KNOW,
HEAT WAVE AND THE, YOU KNOW,
THE ROLLING BLACKOUTS THAT WE
HAD TO FACE.
SO, AS YOU KNOW, THAT, YOU KNOW,
AS WE WERE, UM,
THINKING THROUGH THAT YEAR,
I WANT TO JUST SITUATE YOU ON
THIS,
ON THIS VISUAL ON THE TOP IS,
IS THE PLANNING AND THAT
WHAT WE WERE PLANNING FOR GOING
INTO THE YEAR.
WHAT WERE THE EVENTS THAT WE'VE
SEEN
AND THEN HOW WERE WE MODIFYING?
SO IN TERMS OF PLANNING THE
IN 2020,
WE WERE ALWAYS LOOKING AT
HISTORIC CONDITIONS
AND WHETHER THEY ARE IN A
TEMPERATURE,
WHETHER THEY ARE PRODUCTION
AND SUCH.
AND THEN WE WOULD ALWAYS LOOK
FOR
AVERAGE CLIMATE CHANGE TRENDS.
THOSE WERE WHAT USED TO BE USED
TO KIND
OF GO INTO OUR PLANNING REGIME.
THERE WAS ALWAYS SOME LEVEL OF
CLIMATE IMPACTS BAKED IN,
BUT NOT SIGNIFICANT ENOUGH.
BUT AS, AS YOU KNOW, IN 2020,
THE EXTREME HEAT WAVE THAT WE
HAD, UH,
PUSHED OUR OVERARCHING DEMAND
FROM
A MEDIAN FORECAST BY ABOUT 9%.
SO WE'VE NEVER SEEN SOMETHING
THAT LARGE.
IT WAS A HUGE, SIGNIFICANT
EVENT.
SO GOING INTO 2021, WE REALLY
STARTED INCORPORATING
SOME OF THOSE CLIMATE
UNCERTAINTIES.
AND THEN WE STARTED MORE
ACTIVELY
LOOKING AT A PROCUREMENT.
AND HOW DO WE LOOK AT THESE
UNCERTAINTIES
MOVING FORWARD
AND BEGINNING TO INCREASE
THE PLANNING RESERVE MARGIN,
LOOKING AT THESE CLIMATE CHANGE
IMPACTS.
BUT AS YOU KNOW, IN 2021, IN
JULY WE HAD
THE BOOTLEG FIRE AND THE BOOTLEG
FIRE,
YOU KNOW, KNOCKED OUT ABOUT
4000MW OF
TRANSMISSION COMING INTO
CALIFORNIA.
AND THIS HAPPENED IN OREGON.
AND SUDDENLY OVER, OVER, YOU
KNOW,
IN A SEVERAL MOMENTS,
WE JUST LOST A LARGE AMOUNT OF
INFLOW
OF ENERGY INTO THE INTO THE
STATE.
WE ALSO HIT EXTREME DROUGHT.
WE HAD THE FIRST TIME WE HAD
OROVILLE,
YOU KNOW, KIND OF BOTTOM OUT.
WE HAD WILDFIRES.
AND THEN THIS WAS THE BEGINNING
OF THE REAL
IMPACT OF SUPPLY CHAIN ON THE
SYSTEM.
SO AS WE WERE LOOKING AT THOSE
ISSUES, YOU KNOW,
WE TRIED TO PREPARE FOR THAT
GOING INTO 2022.
AND THE REASSESSMENT OF THAT WAS
WAS LOOKING AT
PLANNING IN TERMS OF PLANNING
RESERVE MARGIN
AND THE STATE AGENCIES REALLY
WERE IN FRONT OF YOU
REQUESTING THE TOOL OF A
STRATEGIC RESERVE,
BECAUSE THE UNCERTAINTIES WERE
SO LARGE
AND WE REALLY NEEDED TO HAVE
SOME CUSHION TO THINK THROUGH AS
WE MOVE FORWARD AGAIN IN 2022.
AS YOU KNOW, SEPTEMBER 6TH WAS
A REALLY,
REALLY HOT DAY IN CALIFORNIA.
BUT ACROSS THE WEST WE HIT
53,000MW
ALMOST ON KAISER SYSTEM AND THAT
REALLY PUT US IN
ONE OF THE HIGHEST GRID LOADS
ACROSS THE WEST.
BUT WE WERE ABLE TO GET THROUGH
THAT IN A GIVEN A NUMBER
OF TOOLS THAT WE WERE ALREADY
USING IN 2023.
WE HAD, YOU KNOW, FURTHER, UM,
KIND OF ONE STATISTIC I WOULD
LIKE TO JUST LEAVE WITH YOU.
SEPTEMBER 6TH, 2022.
WE HAD APPROXIMATELY 53,000MW
IN KAISER SYSTEM.
SAME DAY, SEPTEMBER 6TH, 2023,
WE HAD 33,000.
IT WAS A 20,000
MEGAWATT DIFFERENCE ON
THE SAME DAY, TWO YEARS APART.
AND I THINK THAT'S THE
UNCERTAINTY WE NEED
TO PLAN FOR AS WE MOVE FORWARD
2024.
WE JUST WENT THROUGH A HEAT
WAVE.
THERE ARE FIRES GOING ON.
AGAIN.
I WANT TO JUST TAKE A MOMENT
HERE TO RECOGNIZE,
ON BEHALF OF ALL THE STATE
AGENCIES,
THE INCREDIBLE WORK THAT THE
FIREFIGHTERS
DO IN PUTTING THEIR LIVES
ON ONLINE TO HELP TO NOT ONLY
SAVE LIVES,
BUT ALSO SAVE THE GRID.
SO THANKS TO ALL THE PUBLIC
SERVANTS
WHO ARE WORKING ON THAT FRONT.
SO THEN KIND OF COMING OFF OF
THAT KIND OF OVERARCHING
COMPOUNDING IMPACTS AND HOW DO
WE DEAL WITH THIS?
YOU KNOW, REALLY THE GRID
RELIABILITY
IS LARGELY THE ACTIONS
THAT WE'VE TAKEN LARGELY FALL
INTO THREE PIECES,
WHICH IS IMPROVING OUR GRID
PLANNING PROCESSES
AND KIND OF THAT DRIVES BETTER
PROCUREMENT.
AND PRESIDENT REYNOLDS IS GOING
TO TALK ABOUT THAT IN A SECOND.
WE ALSO LOOKED AT HOW CAN WE
SCALE
THE SUPPLY SIDE AND DEMAND SIDE
RESOURCES.
ONE OF THE IMPORTANT PARTS OF
THAT WAS
TO REALLY TRACK THE PROCUREMENT,
AND THIS IS THROUGH A
MULTI-AGENCY EFFORT
THAT'S CALLED THE TECH TASK
FORCE.
WE WORK THROUGH TRACKING EVERY
EVERY PROJECT IN DEVELOPMENT.
UM, YOU KNOW, ALSO, THE
LEGISLATURE ACTED ON
A NUMBER OF THINGS
INTERCONNECTION, UM,
IMPROVING INTERCONNECTION
THROUGH
THE KAISER PROCESS,
BUT ALSO SOME TOOLS THAT WE WERE
GIVEN ON THE PERMITTING SIDE.
AND FINALLY, YOU KNOW, WE'VE
MADE IT
A REALLY IMPORTANT PART OF THE
PLANNING,
WHICH IS CALLED NOW THE
PREPARING
FOR EXTREME EVENTS.
AND HOW DO WE PLAN FOR THAT?
SO WITH THAT, I'LL PASS IT TO
PRESTON.
PRESIDENT.
OKAY.
AS YOU HEARD, ELECTRIC SYSTEM
PLANNING REQUIRES
SIGNIFICANT COOPERATION AMONG
AGENCIES.
AND EACH OF US HAVE A DIFFERENT
ROLE IN THAT PROCESS.
I'M GOING TO TALK A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT CPUC
S PIECE IN THE PLANNING PROCESS,
INCLUDING OUR PLANNING OVERSIGHT
OVER
THE MORE THAN 40 LOAD SERVING
ENTITIES.
THE CHAIR MENTIONED THIS TODAY.
WE HAVE A NUMBER OF RETAIL
SAILORS WITHIN
CALIFORNIA WITHIN THE PUC'S
JURISDICTION,
INCLUDING THE INVESTOR OWNED
UTILITIES PGE,
SGA, AND SCE, AS WELL AS
COMMUNITY CHOICE
AGGREGATORS AND DIRECT ACCESS
PROVIDERS.
IN TOTAL, ABOUT 75% OF
CALIFORNIA'S
LOAD IS SERVED BY THE LOAD
SERVING ENTITIES THAT ARE PART
OF THE PUC PLANNING PROCESS,
AND THESE LOAD SERVING ENTITIES,
OF COURSE,
HAVE THE RESPONSIBILITY FOR
SERVING THEIR CUSTOMERS,
AND THEY DETERMINE WHICH
PROJECTS WILL
SERVE THESE CUSTOMERS THROUGH
COMPETITIVE
BIDDING AND AGREEMENTS TO
PURCHASE POWER.
WE RECENTLY FOUND, EXCUSE ME,
FOUND IT NECESSARY
TO ORDER PROCUREMENT OF NEW
RESOURCES
TO SERVE CUSTOMER LOAD AND TO
REACH
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSION TARGETS.
AND WHAT YOU'LL SEE ON THIS
SLIDE IS THE VARIOUS
ORDERS THAT WE'VE ISSUED SINCE
2021.
UM, IN PARTICULAR, WE HAVE
ISSUED ORDERS
TO FOLLOW THE 2020 HEAT WAVE.
UM, AND BEGINNING WE ACTUALLY
BEGAN IN 2019.
THE ONLINE DATES COMING FROM
THOSE
ORDERS ARE SHOWN IN THIS SLIDE.
UM, IN TOTAL, WE REACHED AN
UNPRECEDENTED AMOUNT
OF NEARLY 19GW OF NET QUALIFYING
CAPACITY,
MEANING THE VALUE OF THESE
RESOURCES TO THE GRID,
NOT THE MAXIMUM CAPACITY OF THE
PROJECT ORDERED
TO BE BROUGHT ONLINE BETWEEN
2021 AND 2028.
IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT TO NOTE
THAT THESE
ORDERS ARE FOR CLEAN ENERGY
ONLY.
THE REQUIREMENTS CANNOT BE MET
WITH FOSSIL FUEL RESOURCES,
AND THAT MEANS THAT ANY
INCREMENTAL
LOAD THAT WITHIN THE IOU
TERRITORY.
SO ANY OF THESE LOSSES WILL
BE SERVED BY CLEAN ENERGY.
AND EVEN EXISTING LOAD THAT IS
BEING SERVED BY CLEAN ENERGY
PROJECTS THAT THE LSCS ARE NOW
BRINGING ONLINE.
I WANT TO NOTE THAT HOW OUR
THE PROCESS THAT WE USE TO
ARRIVE AT THESE NUMBERS IS BASED
ON CARB SCOPING PLAN.
SO WE LOOK AT THE GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSION TARGET FOR
THE ELECTRIC SECTOR AND TAKE
THE PORTION OF THAT WE TAKE
THE PORTION OF THE TOTAL
GREENHOUSE
GAS EMISSION NUMBER
AND USE THE PORTION THAT APPLIES
TO THE ELECTRIC SECTOR,
AND THEN CALCULATE WHAT'S NEEDED
OVER TIME TO REACH
THE ULTIMATE TARGET OF CLIMATE
NEUTRALITY BY 2045.
OUR ANALYSIS IS ALWAYS BASED
ON THE SIX DEMAND FORECAST.
EACH YEAR, WE UPDATE OUR
PLANNING
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE TRACKING
CHANGING DEMAND OVER TIME TO
REFLECT LOAD GROWTH,
AND THAT WE'RE PREPARED FOR
THOSE
WORST DAYS OF EVERY MONTH.
AND OUR GOAL IS TO IDENTIFY
THE NEED
FOR NEW RESOURCES WELL IN
ADVANCE,
BECAUSE WE KNOW IT TAKES TIME
TO BUILD THESE PROJECTS,
AND THEN WE DO OUR PART TO
ENSURE
THAT THE RESOURCES ARE
CONTRACTED
FOR AND BROUGHT ONLINE ACCORDING
TO THAT SCHEDULE.
UM, THIS, UH, THIS OVERVIEW
SHOWS THAT, UM, THE,
THE PROCUREMENT THAT IS, IS
ORDERED IN ADVANCE.
AND I'M GOING TO GO TO THE NEXT
SLIDE.
UM, WHICH BUILDS ON WHAT WE'VE
DIRECTED
IN PROCUREMENT ORDERS.
SO THIS SLIDE SHOWS THE
MEGAWATTS OF NEW NAMEPLATE
CAPACITY THAT HAS COME ONLINE
SINCE 2020.
SO THESE ARE ACTUAL PROJECTS
ON THE LEFT
SIDE OF THE LINE THAT HAVE BEEN
BUILT ACCORDING TO THE
PROCUREMENT ORDERS
AND THE CONTRACTS OF THE LSCS.
AND IT SHOWS THAT THE PACE OF
RESOURCE DEVELOPMENT
HAS NEARLY DOUBLED OVER THE PAST
FOUR YEARS,
DURING WHICH TIME WE INSTALLED
21GW OF NEW CAPACITY,
AND IN 2023 ALONE,
A RECORD OF OVER 5700MW CAME
ONLINE.
THIS RECORD PACE REQUIRES A
COORDINATED EFFORT,
AND THE CPUC, CAISO,
CEC, AND THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE
OF
BUSINESS AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT
MEET REGULARLY THROUGH A
TRACKING
ENERGY DEVELOPMENT OR TED
TASK FORCE TO ASSESS PROGRESS
AND ADDRESS BOTTLENECKS.
SO THAT'S THE BILL THAT HAS
ACTUALLY HAPPENED,
AND WE EXPECT THAT PACE TO
CONTINUE
THROUGH THE NEXT FEW YEARS.
SO IF YOU LOOK AT THE RIGHT SIDE
OF THE LINE,
THOSE THAT IS A DEPICTION OF
PROJECTS
THAT ARE HAVE CONTRACTS.
SO UNDER CONTRACTS WITH LOAD
SERVING
ENTITIES BUT NOT YET BUILT,
AND YOU CAN SEE THAT ROUGHLY
15GW OF ADDITIONAL RESOURCES
ARE UNDER CONTRACT TO LOAD
SERVING ENTITIES.
AND MOVING FORWARD IN THAT
PROCESS TO COME ONLINE.
A MAJORITY OF THIS CAPACITY
IS FROM SOLAR AND STORAGE,
INCLUDING HYBRID RESOURCES THAT
GENERALLY INCLUDE
BOTH SOLAR AND STORAGE
COMPONENTS.
BUT WE'RE ALSO SEEING WIND,
GEOTHERMAL,
AND BIOMASS RESOURCES COME
ONLINE,
SO LOOKING FOR RESOURCE
DIVERSITY THAT CAN
FURTHER IMPROVE SYSTEM
RELIABILITY.
NEXT SLIDE PLEASE.
I DID WANT TO BRIEFLY MENTION
THE CENTRAL PROCUREMENT
MECHANISM.
WE HEARD FROM THE CHAIR ABOUT
THIS THIS MORNING.
SO SEPARATELY FROM THESE
PROCUREMENT ORDERS,
WE DO HAVE A NEW TOOL IN OUR
TOOLBOX.
PURSUANT TO LEGISLATION ENACTED
LAST YEAR, AB 1373,
WHICH ORDERED THE CPUC TO ASSESS
WHETHER
THERE'S A NEED FOR CENTRAL
PROCUREMENT TO BE CONDUCTED BY
THE DEPARTMENT OF WATER
RESOURCES.
AND IF SO, WHAT TYPES OF
RESOURCES ARE
NECESSARY AND IN WHAT QUANTITY?
THIS INITIAL NEED DETERMINATION
MUST BE COMPLETED
BY SEPTEMBER 1ST OF THIS YEAR.
AND SO PURSUANT TO THAT
DIRECTION,
WE DID RELEASE A PROPOSED
DECISION IN JULY,
WHICH WILL BE ON THE AUGUST 22ND
COMMISSION
VOTING MEETING AGENDA.
UM, THE PUC WILL DETERMINE
WHETHER THE WHETHER
TO VOTE ON THE THE PROPOSED
DECISION.
THE PROPOSAL INCLUDES SOME
RESOURCES
AS SHOWN ON THIS SLIDE
UP TO ONE GIGAWATT OF ENHANCED
GEOTHERMAL SYSTEMS,
WITH THE FIRST SOLICITATION
IN 2026.
UH, TWO TYPES OF LONG DURATION
ENERGY
STORAGE ARE ALSO INCLUDED.
FIRST, UP TO ONE GIGAWATT OF 12
PLUS HOUR DURATION STORAGE,
WITH SOLICITATIONS BEGINNING
IN 2026,
FOLLOWED BY SOLICITATIONS IN
2027 OF UP
TO ONE GIGAWATT OF MULTI-DAY
STORAGE.
FINALLY, 7.6GW OF OFFSHORE WIND
WITH
THE FIRST SOLICITATION IN 2027.
THESE RESOURCES WERE SELECTED
BECAUSE THEY ARE
TECHNOLOGIES THAT PRESENT
OPPORTUNITIES
TO HELP CALIFORNIA MEET ITS
GREENHOUSE
GAS EMISSION TARGET GOALS FOR
2025,
2045 AND BEYOND, AND THEY
INCLUDE
EMERGING TECHNOLOGIES
THAT NEED SCALING TO LOWER
COSTS.
SO THE NEXT STEP AFTER AND
I JUST WANT TO BE CLEAR THAT
THE AMOUNTS SHOWN ON THIS SLIDE
ARE A MAXIMUM.
AND SO THE DEPARTMENT OF WATER
RESOURCES
WOULD GO OUT TO SOLICITATIONS
AND DETERMINE WHETHER THEY'RE
REASONABLE BIDS THAT ARE COST
EFFECTIVE ACCORDING AND AND THEN
WOULD GO FORWARD OR THEY THEY
MAY DECIDE TO TO WAIT AND DO
ADDITIONAL
SOLICITATIONS LATER.
UM, THE NEXT STEP AFTER THE
DECISION
IS A SIX MONTH PERIOD TO FOR
THE FOR
THE COMMISSION TO MAKE A REQUEST
FOR
PROCUREMENT FROM DWR AND THEN
DWR.
IF, IF THAT REQUEST IS MADE,
WOULD ATTEMPT TO CENTRALLY
PROCURE ON
BEHALF OF ALL OF THE LOAD
SERVING
ENTITIES WITHIN IOU TERRITORY,
AND THAT MEANS THAT COSTS WOULD
BE SPREAD AMONG
ALL OF THE CUSTOMERS WITHIN IOU
TERRITORY.
UM, AND THAT IS IT FOR THAT
SLIDE.
SO I WILL NOW TURN TO, UH,
PRESIDENT MANSUR.
>> THANK YOU, PRESIDENT
REYNOLDS.
MR.
CHAIRMAN, MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE.
NICE TO BE WITH YOU THIS
MORNING.
I'M JUST GOING TO BRIEFLY TOUCH
ON TRANSMISSION WHEN
YOU WHEN YOU HEAR THESE
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNTS
OF NEW RESOURCE DEVELOPMENT THAT
THE PUC HAS,
HAS ORDERED PROCUREMENT,
OBVIOUSLY,
THEIR KEY FUNCTION FOR US AT THE
CAISO IS TO MAKE
SURE THAT THERE'S SUFFICIENT
TRANSMISSION
CAPACITY AND EFFICIENT
ONBOARDING OF
THOSE RESOURCES ONTO THE SYSTEM.
SO IN RECENT YEARS, IN VERY
CLOSE COLLABORATION
WITH THE STATE AGENCY,
THE CAISO HAS HAS DEVELOPED WHAT
I WOULD
CHARACTERIZE AS TRANSFORMATIVE
CHANGES
TO OUR TRANSMISSION PLANNING AND
INTERCONNECTION
QUEUING TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE CAN KEEP THE STATE ON
TRACK
FOR ITS CLEAN ENERGY OBJECTIVES.
A COUPLE OF THINGS I WANTED TO
POINT OUT.
FIRST OF ALL, WE'VE ADOPTED
A NEW APPROACH TO TRANSMISSION
PLANNING IN WHICH WE'VE
EFFECTIVELY
IDENTIFIED A SET OF DISCRETE
ZONES ON
THE TRANSMISSION GRID IN
CALIFORNIA THAT,
BASED OFF THE STATE PLANNING,
MAKE THE MOST ECONOMIC
AND OPERATIONAL SENSE FOR NEW
ENERGY RESOURCE DEVELOPMENT.
AND THOSE ZONES ARE GOING TO
SHAPE
THE PATTERN OF PROCUREMENT
AND INTERCONNECTION QUEUING IN
THE YEARS AHEAD.
A COUPLE OF YEARS AGO, WE ALSO
DEVELOPED
A 20 YEAR TRANSMISSION
OUTLOOK SO WE COULD SORT OF TAKE
A BIG PICTURE,
LOOK AT THE TRANSMISSION
ARCHITECTURE FOR
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA OUT
TO 20.
AND NOW WITH THE RECENT UPDATE
ALL THE WAY OUT TO 2045,
WHICH WILL SET THE STAGE FOR
SUBSEQUENT TRANSMISSION
PLANNING EFFORTS AND PROCUREMENT
OF TRANSMISSION,
WE'VE ALSO MADE SOME VERY
SPECIFIC AND ACTIONABLE
REFORMS TO OUR INTERCONNECTION
QUEUING PROCESS TO BRING NEW
ENERGY RESOURCES
INTO SERVICE AS SOON AS
POSSIBLE.
THIS IS REALLY IMPORTANT, SORT
OF TRYING TO TAKE
THE FRICTION OUT OF THE
INTERCONNECTION
QUEUING PROCESS.
A COUPLE OF EXAMPLES.
WE'VE DEVELOPED A SET OF NEW
SCORING
CRITERIA TO PRIORITIZE
AND ADVANCE THOSE PROJECTS THAT
ARE MOST
READY TO COME ONTO THE SYSTEM
AND ARE LINED UP WITH
THOSE ZONES AND THE STATE'S
PLANNING PROCESS.
AND WE'VE ALSO ESTABLISHED MORE
STRINGENT
VIABILITY CRITERIA FOR PROJECTS
IN THE QUEUE TO ENSURE CONTINUED
PROGRESS
TOWARDS COMMERCIAL OPERATION.
AND JUST LAST WEEK, WE
SUBMITTED, I THINK,
A VERY AMBITIOUS PACKAGE OF
THESE REFORMS.
AFTER OVER A YEAR OF STAKEHOLDER
ENGAGEMENT TO
THE FEDERAL ENERGY REGULATORY
COMMISSION,
HOPING TO HAVE APPROVAL FOR
THOSE BY THIS
FALL AND GET THEM INTO
PRODUCTION.
SO I JUST WANTED TO HIGHLIGHT
SOME
OF THE ELEMENTS OF TRANSMISSION.
THAT'S A REAL COMMITMENT WE HAVE
HERE AT THE KAISER
TO MAKE THAT PROCESS AS
EFFICIENT AS POSSIBLE.
VICE CHAIR.
GUNNER.
THANK YOU, PRESIDENT MAINZER.
SO NOW, GIVEN THE BACKGROUND
OF OVERALL
PLANNING STATUS AND PROCUREMENT
STATUS,
I WILL GO INTO THE 2024 GRID
OUTLOOK.
WE ARE IN AUGUST, AND SO
THE AUGUST AND SEPTEMBER ARE
TYPICALLY THE KIND OF THE
TIGHTEST GRID, UM, MONTHS.
SO LET US GIVE YOU A QUICK
UPDATE
ON SOME OF THE INFORMATION
THAT WE'VE SHARED WITH THE
LEGISLATURE.
UM, SO THIS SLIDE CAPTURES WHAT
WE WERE EXPECTING
TO ADD THIS YEAR STARTING IN
JANUARY.
UM, AND THIS IS THE FIRST SIX
MONTHS OF PROGRESS.
AND THEN THE NEXT SLIDE WILL GO
OVER MONTH 7 TO 12.
SO IN OUR Q1Q2, UH, RESOURCE
ADDITIONS,
WE WERE HOPING AT THE START OF
THIS YEAR
TO ADD ABOUT 4000MW OF NEW
RESOURCES.
LARGE AMOUNT OF THAT WAS STORAGE
AND IN A SIGNIFICANT
PART OF SOLAR TO COMPLEMENT THE
CHARGING.
SO AS WE LOOK AT THE Q3 REPORT,
YOU KNOW,
WE HAVE SOME ACTUAL INSTALLED
NUMBERS.
SO OUT OF THE 44,100, ROUGHLY
41, 77, TO BE PRECISE,
THAT WE EXPECTED TO ADD IN THE
FIRST SIX MONTHS,
WE WERE ABLE TO ADD ABOUT 3700MW
ONTO
THE GRID IN THE FIRST SIX
MONTHS.
AND IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT TO
NOTE THAT,
YOU KNOW, THE LAST ROW DOWN
THERE,
WHICH YOU WILL SEE 44% DELAY
OR, YOU KNOW,
65%, YOU KNOW, AND SUCH.
SO WHAT THAT IS TRACKING REALLY
IS LOOKING AT BASED ON
THE EXPECTATIONS VERSUS WHAT
ACTUALLY TRACKS IN REALITY.
HOW DELAYED ARE WE IF WE
REMEMBER,
IF JUST TO KIND OF REMIND THE
MEMBERS
HERE COMING OUT OF 2020,
2021, GIVEN THE SUPPLY CHAIN
CHALLENGES,
ONE OF THE THINGS WE SHARED WITH
YOU WAS
WE WERE OBSERVING ABOUT 40%
DELAY, UM,
REGULARLY ON THE SYSTEM, BOTH
BECAUSE
OF WEATHER CONDITIONS,
SUPPLY CHAIN DELAYS AND OTHERS.
BUT AS YOU SEE HERE,
ONE OF THE THINGS WE ARE REALLY
BEGINNING
TO OBSERVE IS MUCH OF THE DELAYS
HAPPEN IN THE FIRST QUARTER,
ESPECIALLY COMING OUT FROM
WINTER EARLY RAINS.
AND YOU HAVE WEATHER CONDITIONS
THAT NECESSARILY DON'T
NECESSARILY TRANSLATE TO BEING
ABLE TO BUILD QUICKLY.
BUT OVER THE LAST FOUR YEARS,
THE DEVELOPMENT CATCHES UP
BY THE MIDDLE OF THE YEAR.
AND REALLY AT THE END OF THE
YEAR, YOU SEE A SURGE
OF CAPACITY ADDITIONS IN THE
LAST QUARTER.
BUT WE WANT TO BE WE WANT TO
REPORT TO YOU
THAT WE ARE SEEING ONE OF THE
BEST,
UM, UH, KIND OF ADDITIONS RATE
THIS YEAR,
WHICH IS AT THE END OF SIX
MONTHS.
WE ARE ONLY AT ABOUT 11% BEHIND
OUR EXPECTATION, ABOUT 400MW.
AND I ALSO WANT TO CALL YOUR
ATTENTION
TO THE TOTAL MEGAWATTS THAT ARE
ADDED.
WE ALMOST ADDED 3700MW.
AND AS PRESIDENT REYNOLDS
MENTIONED,
LAST YEAR WAS A RECORD YEAR
WHERE WE ADDED,
YOU KNOW, CLOSE TO 6000MW LAST
YEAR ONTO THE GRID.
THIS YEAR, WE'RE ALREADY ALMOST
TO
4000MW IN THE FIRST FOUR MONTHS.
AND GOING INTO THE NEXT SLIDE
AND THEN YOU KNOW WHAT?
HOW IS IT LOOKING MOVING FORWARD
BASED ON THE THE KAISER?
Q WHAT WE SEE IS ANOTHER 7.5GW
OF NEW RESOURCES THAT
COULD COME ONLINE OVER THE NEXT
SIX MONTHS.
THAT IS PUTTING US IN THE REALM
OF 10,000MW
THIS YEAR.
OBVIOUSLY, THERE WILL BE DELAYS
AND WE'LL OBSERVE THAT,
BUT IT'S A PRETTY YOU KNOW,
WE FEEL CONFIDENT THAT WE WE
COULD BEAT
THE RECORD LAST YEAR AND HAVE
HIGHER RESOURCES.
AND THIS IS EXACTLY WHAT WE NEED
IN TERMS OF SB 100
BEING ABLE TO BUILD CONSISTENTLY
AT THIS RATE.
SO HOW DOES THAT TRANSLATE THEN
INTO
THE THE KIND OF SEPTEMBER MONTH
FOR YOU?
I MEAN WE WE PRESENT HERE
THE SEPTEMBER BUT ALL JULY UM,
AUGUST AND SEPTEMBER LOOK THE
SAME.
WHAT YOU'RE SEEING HERE IN THE
VERY FIRST, UM,
COLUMN IS LOOKING AT THE Q1
REPORT THAT WE SUBMITTED,
YOU KNOW, EARLIER THIS YEAR.
UM, AND WE WERE SAYING ABOUT
WE HAVE ABOUT 4000MW OF,
OF ADDITIONAL RESOURCES IN IN
ADDITION TO
UM THE THE STANDARD PLANNING
RESOURCES.
SO ONE THING I WANT TO CALL YOUR
ATTENTION TO,
THE RESOURCES WE CONSIDER HERE
ARE NOT ALL UNDER RA, RIGHT.
THIS IS THE STEEL IN THE GROUND,
ALL OF CALIFORNIA AND THE
EXPECTED
IMPORTS COMING INTO THE SYSTEM.
SO WE LOOK AT TWO THINGS AS WE
PLAN FOR SUMMER RELIABILITY.
ONE, ARE WE PLANNING TO THE RA
AND THEN ARE THEY
ARE THERE RESOURCES SHOWING
SHOWING UP?
THAT'S ONE THING.
AND THEN IF WE WERE TO GO BEYOND
THAT STANDARD
PLANNING EVENT AND TO AN EXTREME
EVENT,
DO WE HAVE ENOUGH RESOURCES IN
CALIFORNIA
THAT WE CAN RELY ON TO GET
THROUGH THAT?
AND THAT'S WHERE EVEN THOUGH
THERE
ARE RESOURCES, YOU KNOW,
IN CALIFORNIA, YOU WILL SEE,
YOU KNOW,
SOME GRID TIGHTNESS,
WHETHER IT'S AN ALERT
TRANSMISSION ALERT,
WHETHER IT'S AN EMERGENCY WATCH,
BECAUSE WE'RE TRYING TO MOBILIZE
THOSE
RESOURCES TO SUPPORT THE GRID.
SO IF IT'S A 2020 EVENT, AGAIN,
2020 WAS THAT APPROXIMATELY 8
TO 9% DEVIATION
FROM A MEDIAN DEMAND FORECAST.
AND 2022 WAS IN THE REALM OF
12%.
SO YOU'RE LOOKING AT VERY HIGH
DEMANDS BAKED INTO IT.
AND ALSO SOME, UM, UH, YOU KNOW,
DROUGHT RISKS.
UM, NOT FOR THIS YEAR, BUT
TYPICALLY WE WE PUT THAT
IN THERE AND HIGHER OUTAGE RISKS
OF THERMAL FLEET.
SO AS YOU'RE SEEING HERE WE'RE
LOOKING BETTER AND BETTER
BECAUSE OF THE ADDITIONS WE WERE
ABLE TO HAVE.
SO UNDER NONE OF THOSE
CONDITIONS
WE SEE SHORTFALLS AT THIS POINT.
SO THEN KIND OF GOING INTO THE
STRATEGIC
RELIABILITY RESERVE REAL QUICK.
SO NOW THAT, YOU KNOW, WE JUST
SHARED WITH YOU, UM,
AS WE LOOK AT THE DEMAND AND
RESOURCES
AND PLANNING FOR EXTREME EVENTS,
WE HAVE ENOUGH STEEL IN THE
GROUND TO POTENTIALLY
CARRY US THROUGH A VERY EXTREME
EVENT.
BUT THEN HOW DO YOU MOBILIZE
THEM AND HOW
ARE YOU KIND OF PLANNING FOR
THEM?
THAT'S WHAT I'M GOING TO COVER
HERE.
SO BEFORE WE GO INTO THE ACTUAL
CONTINGENCY AMOUNTS WE HAVE,
WE JUST WANT TO SET THE STAGE
ON TWO,
TWO TYPES OF EVENTS.
WE ARE NOW BEGINNING TO TRACK.
ONE.
IS THE SUDDEN ONSET.
A PRIMARY EXAMPLE FOR THAT WOULD
BE A FIRE
KNOCKING OUT A TRANSMISSION
LINE.
THAT HAPPENS VERY, VERY QUICKLY.
AND THE NUMBER OF RESOURCES
WE WE
CAN RELY ON IS VERY DIFFERENT
VERSUS A SLOW MOVING LIKE WHAT
WE SAW IN JULY.
SO WHEN YOU HAVE THREE, 4 OR 5
DAYS ADVANCE
NOTICE AND THEN A LONG HEAT WAVE
COMING,
YOU CAN MOBILIZE A LOT MORE
RESOURCES.
AND SO THAT'S KIND OF WHAT THIS
IS TRYING TO CAPTURE HERE.
AND AGAIN WANT TO REALLY
REEMPHASIZE THIS.
WE ARE MEETING OUR OBLIGATIONS
AS WE SEE.
AND YOU KNOW, IF IT'S A STANDARD
EVENT, YOU KNOW,
WE HAVE ENOUGH RESOURCES UNDER
OUR
CONTRACTS TO GET US THROUGH
THAT.
IF IT'S AN EXTREME EVENT, WE
HAVE ENOUGH STEEL IN
THE GROUND AND CONTINGENCIES
TO CARRY US THROUGH THAT.
BUT THAT DOESN'T MEAN THAT WE
WILL NOT
SEE SOME OF THE EMERGENCY
ALERTS,
UM, YOU KNOW, TO, TO PREP AND
ARM THOSE RESOURCES.
SO AGAIN, KIND OF THEN KIND OF
TAKING
A STEP BACK ON THIS SLIDE,
WE WANT TO JUST REMIND YOU WHEN
WE ASKED
PLANNING FOR STRATEGIC RESERVE,
WE FIRST WANT TO MEET OUR LOSS
OF LOAD EXPECTATION.
WE WANT TO UNDERSTAND THE
DEMAND.
AND WE WANT TO PLAN FOR RESOURCE
PROCUREMENT.
THAT AT LEAST GETS US THROUGH
THE STANDARD RELIABILITY
PLANNING.
AND THEN YOU SHOULD PLAN FOR
THOSE TEN,
20, 30% OF DELAYS,
WHETHER IT'S SUPPLY CHAIN,
WHETHER IT'S SOME OTHER WAY,
YOU KNOW, THERE'S KIND OF
DEVELOPMENTAL DELAYS,
YOU HAVE TO COVER THAT AND THEN
YOU HAVE TO COVER HEAT.
AND THEN FINALLY THESE EXTREME
EVENTS SUCH AS,
YOU KNOW, THE FIRE RISK.
SO WHAT WE PLAN FOR AND YOU SEE
THE STACK THERE IS THE TOP FOUR
IS WHAT THE STRATEGIC RESERVE IS
TRYING TO TRYING TO COVER FOR.
WE PLAN FOR OUR STANDARD.
AND THEN ANYTHING INCREMENTAL
TO THAT STANDARD,
WHETHER IT'S COMING THROUGH
PROCUREMENT DELAYS,
HEART CONDITIONS, FIRES OR
DROUGHT, WE WANT TO HAVE
ENOUGH RESOURCES TO CARRY US
THROUGH THAT.
SO THIS KIND OF SLIDE, SLIDE 19
JUST GIVES YOU
A QUICK LOOK AT THE
CONTINGENCIES WE HAVE.
AND WE HAVE THREE BUCKETS OF
CONTINGENCY RESOURCES.
THE FIRST ONE IS THE STATE
FUNDED
STRATEGIC RELIABILITY RESERVE.
THIS IS WHERE A LARGE PORTION
OF THAT TODAY
IS REALLY DONE THROUGH DWR AND
DIRECTOR,
WHO WILL KIND OF TALK THROUGH
THAT.
AND THERE'S A COUPLE OF PROGRAMS
THAT WERE
FUNDED THROUGH CEC FOR THE
DEMAND,
DEMAND SIDE OPTIONS, WHETHER
IT'S THE DEMAND
SIDE GRID SUPPORT OR BACKUP
ASSETS.
YOU KNOW, WE WILL TALK THROUGH
THAT IN A BIT.
WE HAVE A BUNCH OF PROGRAMS THAT
ARE ACTUALLY
PAID THROUGH THE RATE PAYERS
STILL,
AND THAT PUC PAYS FOR THAT.
THE PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION,
YOU KNOW,
AUTHORIZES THEM THROUGH THE
RATEPAYER MONIES.
AND SO WE HAVE THE EMERGENCY
LOAD REDUCTION PROGRAM,
WHICH I'LL GIVE PRESIDENT
REYNOLDS TO GIVE
A QUICK OVERVIEW ABOUT THE CPUC
PROGRAMS.
SURE.
SO AS MENTIONED BY THE VICE
CHAIR,
THERE ARE SEVERAL PROGRAMS THAT
WE DEPLOY IN EMERGENCIES THAT
ARE
PAID FOR BY UTILITY RATEPAYERS.
SO CUSTOMERS PAY FOR THESE
PROGRAMS
THROUGH THE THEIR UTILITY BILLS.
IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE, THOUGH,
THAT THE PROGRAMS ARE DESIGNED
TO
BE USED IN EMERGENCIES ONLY,
SO CUSTOMERS ARE NOT PAYING FOR
THIS EITHER
LOAD REDUCTION OR ADDITIONAL
SUPPLY.
365 DAYS OF THE YEAR.
THEY'RE ONLY PAYING FOR IT A FEW
DAYS OF THE YEAR
BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT'S WHAT WILL
BE NEEDED.
SO THE IDEA IS THAT WE HAVE
ADDITIONAL LOAD REDUCTION
AND ADDITIONAL SUPPLY AVAILABLE
ON A FEW DAYS OF THE YEAR.
UM, THE MAIN EXAMPLE OF ONE OF
THESE PROGRAMS IS
THE EMERGENCY LOAD REDUCTION
PROGRAM, OR THE LRP,
WHICH PAYS RESIDENTIAL AND
COMMERCIAL CUSTOMERS
TO REDUCE THEIR LOAD DURING
EMERGENCIES.
SO IT'S A PAY FOR PERFORMANCE
PROGRAM.
IT'S TRIGGERED WHEN CAISO CALLS
A FLEX
ALERT OR OTHER EMERGENCY ALERTS.
AND ANOTHER EXAMPLE IS
THE SMART THERMOSTAT PROGRAMS.
AND SO THIS IS AN AUTOMATIC
ADJUSTMENT
TO CUSTOMER'S AIR CONDITION
SETTINGS
TO REDUCE ELECTRICITY LOAD AT
TIMES
OF GRID STRESS OR HIGH PRICES.
AND THE INVESTOR OWNED UTILITIES
HAVE ALSO SIGNED CONTRACTS.
SO THAT IS THE SECOND LINE ON
THE CHART UNDER THE CPUC
SECTION,
UM, TO BRING IN ADDITIONAL
ENERGY IMPORTS.
AND THESE ARE FIRM CONTRACTS
WHERE THAT ENERGY SUPPLY
IS GUARANTEED INTO CALIFORNIA
WHEN NEEDED.
UM, WITH THE INVESTOR OWNED
UTILITIES
HAVE ALSO SIGNED NEW
CONTRACTS WITH SEVERAL COMBINED
HEAT AND POWER FACILITIES.
SO THESE ARE OLDER CONTRACTS
THAT WERE
WRAPPING UP AND THAT SUPPLY JUST
GOT PICKED UP FOR ADDITIONAL
YEARS
AND CAN BE DEPLOYED IN
EMERGENCIES.
THANK YOU, PRESIDENT DANIELS.
AND SO THE LAST CATEGORY OF THAT
IS THE NON PROGRAMMATIC.
THESE ARE MORE DONE THROUGH UM
WORK FROM KAISER FOR EXAMPLE.
THEY WORK WITH LADWP AND OTHERS
ON
FIGURING OUT HOW EACH BALANCING
AREAS CAN SUPPORT EACH OTHER UM
DURING EMERGENCIES.
AND ALSO THERE'S A COUPLE OF
EXTRAORDINARY
EVENTS WE CAN DO THROUGH
EITHER AN EMERGENCY PROCLAMATION
OR WAIVERS THROUGH DOE,
WHERE WE CAN GO BEYOND PERMIT
LEVELS,
WHICH WE HAVE DEPLOYED UM IN
PREVIOUS YEARS.
SO.
APOLOGIES.
THAT KEEPS BUGGING ON ME.
UM, SO WITH THAT, I'LL GO INTO
THE NEXT SLIDE
AND JUST START WITH THE STATE
FUNDED PROGRAMS.
THANK YOU VICE CHAIR.
GOOD MORNING.
>> CHAIR.
GOOD MORNING MEMBERS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR INVITING
ME.
SO I WILL TALK A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT ONE OF
THE STATE'S STRATEGIC RESERVE
PROGRAMS.
AND THAT IS DWR'S PROGRAM UNDER
THE ELECTRICITY
SUPPLY STRATEGIC RELIABILITY
RESERVE PORTFOLIO.
SO THROUGH AB CREATED THROUGH
AB 205 AND 209,
IT ACTS AS AN INSURANCE POLICY
AND SAFEGUARDS THE STATEWIDE
ELECTRIC GRID
DURING EXTREME AND COMBINED
EVENTS.
AS VICE CHAIR, GUNDY WAS
DESCRIBING
SUCH AS HEATWAVES,
WILDFIRES, DROUGHTS DRIVEN BY
CLIMATE CHANGE.
SO THE TABLE BEFORE YOU INCLUDES
ALSO
THE STATE POWER AUGMENTATION
PROGRAM,
WHICH WAS DEVELOPED THROUGH AN
EMERGENCY
PROCLAMATION BY THE GOVERNOR
IN 2021,
AS WELL AS THE SRP FROM ITS
INCEPTION
IN 2022 THROUGH TODAY.
AS YOU CAN SEE, THE PORTFOLIO
PORTFOLIO
HAS MOVED AWAY FROM,
FOR EXAMPLE, TEMPORARY DIESEL
GENERATORS,
WHICH WERE DEPLOYED IN AN
EMERGENCY AND USED
DURING THE SEPTEMBER 2022 HEAT
WAVE.
AND WE'VE TRANSITIONED AWAY FROM
THAT TO MUCH LOWER EMITTING
NATURAL GAS RESOURCES AT THE
POINT IN TIME.
IN 22 AND 23, WE ALSO RELIED
HEAVILY
ON IMPORTS AS WE WERE TRYING
TO RAMP UP THE PROGRAM AND BUILD
OUT NEW ASSETS IN THE STATES.
THE MAJOR SHIFT THEN IS YOU
CAN SEE
AS WE TRANSITION AWAY FROM
IMPORTS,
IS THE ENTRY OF THE ONCE THROUGH
COOLING RESOURCES
INTO OUR PORTFOLIO EARLY THIS
YEAR.
AND THAT WAS ON THE
RECOMMENDATION
OF THE STATE ADVISORY
ADVISORY COMMITTEE ON COOLING
WATER INTAKE STRUCTURES,
WHICH INCLUDES THE CALIFORNIA
ISO, CPUC, AND CEC,
RECOMMENDING TO THE STATE WATER
RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD
TO ALLOW FOR THE EXTENSION OF
ONCE THROUGH COOLING,
RESOURCE PERMITTING, SO THAT
IT CAN BE
PROVIDED INTO THE STRATEGIC
RESERVE.
THE BIG TRADE OFF AND BENEFIT OF
THAT IS THAT THOSE RESOURCES
WOULD BE REMOVED FROM THE
RESOURCE ADEQUACY PROGRAM.
AND AS VICE CHAIRMAN HAS, UM,
UH, DESCRIBED EARLIER,
THOSE ARE PART OF THE
TRADITIONAL STATE
LEVEL RESOURCE PLANNING UNDER
THE CPUC,
AND THEY ARE EXPECTED ONCE THEY
ARE WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ISO TO BE AVAILABLE 24 HOURS
A DAY,
SEVEN DAYS A WEEK.
SO THE BIG SEA CHANGE IN THE
OPERATION
OF THE ONCE THROUGH COOLING
RESOURCES
AND ALL THE RESOURCES IN THE
RESERVE IS THAT
THEY ARE DEFAULT OFF, THEY ARE
NOT OFF,
AND THEY ARE NOT OPERATING
UNLESS FOR TESTING
PURPOSES OR ORDERED BY THE
CALIFORNIA ISO,
OR TRIGGERED BY AN EMERGENCY
REQUIRED
FOR THEM TO OPERATE.
SO THAT'S A BIG CHANGE IN
OPERATIONS AND A BIG
REDUCTION IN THE EMISSIONS OF
THESE RESOURCES.
AND AS WE'LL DISCUSS A LITTLE
BIT MORE IN THE NEXT SECTION,
WITH THESE RESOURCES, FROM THE
ONCE
THROUGH COOLING RESOURCES,
AS WELL AS ADDITIONAL RESOURCES
THAT WE HAVE WITH
THE COMBINATION OF LOW EMITTING
NATURAL GAS RESOURCES,
UM, THE RESERVE IS AVAILABLE
TO RESPOND
TO ANY NEEDS OF THE STATE.
AND I'LL JUST GIVE YOU A LITTLE
PREVIEW OF THAT.
FROM THE PERSPECTIVE OF THE
DEPARTMENT
OF WATER RESOURCES,
I KNOW IT WAS BARELY A MONTH
AGO THAT WE
WENT THROUGH THE THOMPSON FIRE
AND THAT
FIRST LARGE FIRE IN THE STATE
WE HAD WE
SAW THE CITY OF OROVILLE
EVACUATED,
AND IN THAT EVENT, IT CAUSED
A TRANSMISSION LINES TO RELAY.
AND WHAT HAPPENED THERE IS THAT
WE LOST
POWER TO THE OROVILLE COMPLEX.
SO THAT WAS A REDUCTION OF 800MW
IN
THE BLINK OF AN EYE TO THE GRID.
SO THANKFULLY, KAISER WAS ABLE
TO OPERATE
THE GRID IN A SAFE AND RELIABLE
MANNER.
CAL FIRE WAS EVENTUALLY ABLE TO
GET THE FIRE UNDER CONTROL.
POWER WAS RESTORED, AND IN THAT
INSTANCE THE RESERVE WAS READY
AND PART OF IT WAS USED TO HELP
THROUGH THAT EVENT.
AND AGAIN AS VICE CHAIR, GUNDY
HAD MENTIONED,
WE CONTINUE TO EXPERIENCE HEAT
EVENTS AND OTHER FIRES
SUCH AS THE PARK FIRE THROUGHOUT
THE STATE.
SO AGAIN, THE RESERVE IS READY
AND AVAILABLE WITH THE MEGAWATTS
SHOWN HERE IN THE 2024 COLUMN
TO HELP THE STATE.
WITH THAT, LET ME TURN IT BACK
TO VICE CHAIR GUNDA.
THANK YOU DIRECTOR.
SO WE HAVE ONE MORE SLIDE ON.
JUST KIND OF EXPANDING ON
THE DGS AND THE DBA PROGRAMS.
UM, WANT TO JUST AGAIN THANK THE
LEGISLATURE
FOR THIS FUNDING STREAM,
AND ESPECIALLY BECAUSE IT GIVES
US AN OPPORTUNITY TO DEVELOP
DEMAND SIDE PROGRAMS WITHOUT
RATEPAYER SUPPORT.
SO I WANT TO, UM,
JUST REALLY STRESS ON THE WORK
THAT
WE'RE DOING ON PROVIDING
FLEXIBLE OPTIONS TO,
TO DEVELOPING THE DEMAND SIDE
PROGRAM.
SO WE ARE LOOKING AT ABOUT 444MW
AS OF AUGUST 2024.
AND IN REALLY KIND OF MOVING
TOWARDS
THREE TYPES OF PROGRAMS WITHIN
THAT.
BUT I WANT TO JUST HIGHLIGHT
OPTION THREE,
WHICH HAS BECOME REALLY
SUCCESSFUL WITH WITH KIND OF
USING BEHIND THE METER STORAGE
TO DEVELOP VPPS.
AND SO WE HAVE ABOUT 210MW TODAY
ENROLLED IN THE PROGRAM.
AND WE EXPECT THAT TO CONTINUE
TO GROW.
ON THE DBA, GIVEN THAT IT'S
A DIFFERENT TYPE OF, YOU KNOW,
RESOURCE STREAM AND THAT WE ARE
BEGINNING
TO PUT OUT SOLICITATIONS,
WE ALREADY HAVE A SOLICITATION
OUT,
AND THAT IS GOING TO BE ADDING
MORE
RESOURCES IN THE 2026 TIME
FRAME.
AND THE REASON FOR, UM,
OUR FOCUS ON DSTS WAS REALLY
THE QUICK,
THE ABILITY TO QUICKLY BRING IN
MEGAWATTS UNDER THIS PROGRAM.
SO WITH THAT, WE'LL GO INTO
THE SUMMER 2024 GRID UPDATE,
ESPECIALLY THE JULY EVENT,
AND I'LL PASS IT TO PRESIDENT
MEINZER.
THANK YOU, VICE CHAIR.
SO YES, I'D LIKE TO OFFER A
NUMBER OF OBSERVATIONS
ABOUT SUMMER 2024 CONDITIONS,
SORT OF FROM THE PERSPECTIVE
OF GRID OPERATIONS, I THINK.
I THINK THE BOTTOM LINE SO FAR
IS THAT
THINGS HAVE BEEN GOING QUITE
WELL.
IT HAS BEEN A CHALLENGING
SUMMER.
WE'VE HAD SOME VERY, VERY HIGH
TEMPERATURES
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA AND THE
BROADER WEST.
IN FACT, THE BROADER WESTERN
UNITED STATES SET
ITS ALL TIME DEMAND RECORD BACK
ON JULY 10TH.
SO IT HAS BEEN HOT.
BUT FORTUNATELY HERE INSIDE
CALIFORNIA,
WE HAVEN'T HAD TRULY EXCEPTIONAL
SORT OF STATEWIDE CONDITIONS.
I THINK IF YOU THINK BACK TO
SEPTEMBER 6TH,
2022, WE HIT A 52,061
MEGAWATT PEAK ARE THE HIGHEST
LOAD WE'VE
HAD SO FAR THIS SUMMER IS
45,426MW.
SO WE'VE BEEN FORTUNATE SO FAR
THAT THE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA COASTLINE HASN'T
REALLY HEATED UP.
SO WE HAVEN'T HAD EXCEPTIONAL
HEAT,
BUT WE HAVE HAD SOME CHALLENGES.
AND I THINK THE ALL OF THE
PLANNING
AND PROCUREMENT AS WE'LL TALK
HAS PAID OFF.
WELL, I THINK WE ONE OF THE
THINGS WE'RE WATCHING
VERY CAREFULLY ARE THE
WILDFIRES.
AND JUST AS WAS MENTIONED
PREVIOUSLY,
RIGHT NOW THE PARK FIRE HAS
PUT SOME
STRAIN ON THE TRANSMISSION GRID,
SO WE'RE WATCHING THAT VERY
CAREFULLY AGAIN.
DEEP APPRECIATION TO CAL FIRE
AND ALL THE FIREFIGHTERS
DOING AN INCREDIBLE JOB UP
THERE.
BUT SO FAR THE THE IMPACTS ON
THE BULK GRID
HAVE BEEN MANAGEABLE AT THIS
STAGE.
UM, THE ENERGY RESOURCES THAT
HAVE COME ONLINE
THE LAST COUPLE OF YEARS HAVE
MADE A REAL DIFFERENCE.
AS WE'VE SAID, WE'VE WE NOW
HAVE OVER 9000MW OF FOR OUR
LITHIUM ION BATTERIES OPERATING
ON THE CAISO GRID.
THAT'S THE LARGEST IN NORTH
AMERICA
AND ANYWHERE OUTSIDE OF CHINA.
SO THAT BATTERY FLEET IS REALLY
PERFORMING QUITE WELL.
AND CERTAINLY WE'RE GOING TO BE
CONTINUING TO COORDINATE VERY
CLOSELY WITH OUR STATE PARTNERS
AS SUMMER PROGRESSES,
BECAUSE WE CERTAINLY CONTINUE
TO HAVE EXPOSURE
TO EXTREME CONDITIONS IN AUGUST
AND SEPTEMBER.
I WANT TO JUST PUT A COUPLE OF
EXCLAMATION
POINTS ON A COUPLE OF OTHER
THINGS.
I THINK JUST SOME OF THE KEY
TAKEAWAYS,
YOU KNOW, THE THE,
THE AMOUNT OF NEW GENERATION
THAT
IS COMING ONLINE IN CALIFORNIA
AND THE PLANNING AND THE
PROCUREMENT
HAS BEEN A HUGE DIFFERENCE
MAKER.
RIGHT.
JUST TO HAVE TO BE MEETING THE
1 IN 10 LOSS OF LOAD
STANDARD INSIDE CALIFORNIA AND
TO HAVE A MUCH,
MUCH MORE ROBUST RESOURCE
ADEQUACY
STACK HAS JUST MADE
A TREMENDOUS DIFFERENCE FOR
RELIABILITY
HERE IN THE STATE.
THE OTHER THING IS I REALLY
WANT TO
EXPRESS MY APPRECIATION, YOU
KNOW,
THE AMOUNT OF PLANNING AND
ADVANCE COORDINATION
THAT GOES INTO THE SUMMERS.
NOW, THE TABLETOP EXERCISES THAT
WE DO WITH THE STATE AGENCIES,
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE, THE
UTILITIES,
ALL THE LOAD SERVING ENTITIES
THAT JUST PAYS
REAL DIVIDENDS BY DOING SCENARIO
PLANNING
AND TRYING TO ANTICIPATE
THE FULL RANGE OF CONDITIONS
THAT WE MIGHT ENCOUNTER DURING
A SUMMER,
AND HAVING A VERY WELL CRAFTED
PLAYBOOK
THAT WE CAN OPERATE OFF,
AND ALL OPERATING ON THE SAME
PAGE.
IT'S BEEN A MAJOR DIFFERENCE
MAKER.
THE OTHER THING IS, AS DELPHINE
WAS MENTIONING, YOU KNOW,
DURING THE MOST RECENT JULY HEAT
WAVE, YOU KNOW,
THE STATE PROGRAMS DESIGNED TO
PROVIDE
GRID SUPPORT DURING EXTREME
WEATHER EVENTS WERE MOBILIZED
AND PERFORMED AS EXPECTED.
I THINK THAT WAS VERY SMOOTH
AND REALLY
APPRECIATE THE COORDINATION
THERE.
ACROSS THE SPECTRUM, THE STATE
STRATEGIC
RESERVE DEMAND RESPONSE,
WE'RE STARTING TO SEE A LITTLE
BIT OF ADDITIONAL DEMAND
RESPONSE PARTICIPATION IN
THE DAY AHEAD ENERGY MARKET.
THAT MAKES A NICE DIFFERENCE.
WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE TO TRY
TO GROW THAT
CAPABILITY HERE IN THE YEARS
AHEAD.
LOAD FLEXIBILITY.
I THINK IN A CENTRAL PART OF THE
RELIABILITY
EQUATION HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
AND THEN FINALLY, THE WESTERN
ENERGY IMBALANCE MARKET,
WHICH WE'LL TALK ABOUT A LITTLE
BIT MORE,
CONTINUED TO BE AN ESSENTIAL
TOOL IN HELPING
TO BALANCE SUPPLY AND DEMAND,
BOTH HERE IN CALIFORNIA AND
ACROSS THE BROADER WEST.
SO I JUST WANTED TO THANK
EVERYBODY FOR THE WORK.
YOUR SUPPORT AND THE LEGISLATURE
HAS BEEN OBVIOUSLY GAME
CHANGING AND JUST IT'S GREAT TO
SEE THE PROGRESS,
BUT WE'LL KEEP OUR HEAD DOWN
AND KEEP MOVING FORWARD.
THANK YOU.
SO I WANT TO JUST TO CALL OUT
ONE OTHER
ADDITIONAL PIECE OF DATA FOR
YOU,
JUST TO KIND OF JUST TO SHOW YOU
ONE OTHER ONE OTHER PIECE,
JUST JUST SORT OF SPEAKING TO
THAT
THE IF YOU IF YOU LOOK AT THE
AMOUNT OF
EMERGENCY NOTIFICATIONS THAT
WE'VE HAD
TO DO IN THE LAST COUPLE OF
YEARS,
UM, YOU'VE SEEN A REAL DECREASE
BACK
IN SEPTEMBER OF 2022 AND THROUGH
THE THROUGH IN THE SUMMER OF
2022,
WE HAD TO CALL 11 FLEX ALERTS.
UH, THE LAST TWO YEARS,
LAST YEAR AND THIS YEAR SO FAR,
NO FLEX ALERTS.
ALSO, YOU CAN SEE BACK IN 2022,
WE HAD A TOTAL OF 19 EMERGENCY
ALERTS IN THE KAISO AREA.
LAST YEAR WE WERE DOWN TO THREE.
THIS YEAR SO FAR ONLY ONE, AND
THAT WAS A QUICK CALL
IN RESPONSE TO THE BREAK OUT OF
THE PARK FIRE.
SO THESE METRICS ARE ALSO
SHOWING
INDICATIONS OF PROGRESS
AND TO SPEAK TO WHAT I WAS
INDICATING EARLIER.
AND YOU CAN ALSO SEE THAT FOR
CALIFORNIA, REALLY,
PARTICULARLY THIS SUMMER AND
LAST SUMMER,
RELATIVE TO THE BROADER WEST,
WHO'S BEEN YOU KNOW,
THE TABLES HAVE SORT OF TURNED
BACK IN 2022.
IT WAS REALLY THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
WE WERE RIGHT ON THE EDGE.
IMPORTS THE WESTERN ENERGY
IMBALANCE MARKET.
WE WERE ABLE TO RECEIVE A LOT
OF SUPPORT FROM
ADJACENT STATES THE LAST COUPLE
OF SUMMERS.
THE TABLES SORT OF TURNED.
WE'VE BEEN IN THE POSITION TO
PROVIDE
SOME BROADER ASSISTANCE.
AND THAT'S SORT OF SPEAKS TO
THE BROADER INTERDEPENDENCE OF
THE WESTERN GRID AND THE
BENEFITS
OF REGIONAL COORDINATION.
SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
AND I'M GOING TO TURN IT BACK TO
VICE CHAIR GUNDA.
THANK YOU, PRESIDENT MEINZER.
MAINZER.
SO WE'RE GOING TO KIND OF
QUICKLY
TEE UP THE TEN YEAR OUTLOOK.
JUST A COUPLE OF SLIDES ON THAT.
AND THEN WE'RE GOING TO GO INTO
THE REASON WE'RE
GOING TO END WITH THE REGIONAL
COORDINATION.
SO ON THE TEN YEAR OUTLOOK UM
JUST WANTED
TO MAKE SURE WE RECOGNIZE, YOU
KNOW,
MUCH OF THE INFORMATION ON THIS
SLIDE IS REALLY REITERATING
SOME OF THE PIECES THAT WE'VE
ALREADY DISCUSSED.
UM, BUT THE THE KIND OF CONSTANT
THAT WE'RE OBSERVING
IS UNKNOWN UNKNOWNS THAT WE ARE
SEEING ON THE GRID.
UM, IN A NEW, NEW TYPES OF
CHALLENGES EMERGE.
BUT FUNDAMENTALLY, THERE ARE TWO
PIECES THAT
WE COULD BEGIN TO BAKE INTO OUR
PLANNING,
WHICH IS HIGH ELECTRIFICATION
AND THINKING ABOUT
HOW WE CAN PLAN FOR HIGH
ELECTRIFICATION.
UM, CHAIR, UH, BRADFORD
MENTIONED IN HIS OPENING
COMMENTS ABOUT THE INCREASING
AI LOAD.
WE JUST HAD A WORKSHOP
SPECIFICALLY ON THAT,
THINKING ABOUT HOW DO WE EVEN
THINK ABOUT THAT,
THAT UPCOMING AI LOAD.
SO WE'RE DOING WHAT WE CAN IN
TERMS OF THE KNOWN VARIABLES,
HIGH ELECTRIFICATION AND HIGH
VARIABILITY
IN THE WEATHER PATTERNS.
BUT I THINK THE CHALLENGES
CONTINUE
TO COME FROM THE UNKNOWN
UNKNOWNS IN TERMS OF HOW THEY
HIT OUR SUPPLY SIDE.
AND SO SOME OF THE SPECIFIC
EXAMPLES
AGAIN WERE NOTED HERE.
SO JUST GIVING YOU A SLIDE 28.
JUST GIVING YOU A QUICK
PROJECTION.
BOTH THE FREQUENCY AND THE
MAGNITUDE
OF HEAT IS EXPECTED
TO GROW OVER THE NEXT, YOU KNOW,
70 YEARS.
BUT REALLY KIND OF I THINK MY
MY MAIN KIND OF TAKEAWAY HERE
IS SOME OF THE CLIMATE
PROJECTIONS
WE WERE HAVING IN 2010,
2015 TIME FRAME THAT WERE
SUGGESTING
THE IMPACTS THAT
WE'RE SEEING TODAY TO SHOW UP
IN 2030, 2035.
SO WE'RE REALLY SEEING AN
EARLIER KIND OF IMPACTS
OF CLIMATE CHANGE THAN THAN WE
HAVE ANTICIPATED.
AND THE LENGTH THE LENGTH OF
THE EVENTS ARE ALSO INCREASING.
SO ONE OF THE PIECES THAT WE
WILL CONTINUE
TO SEE HERE IS LONG HEATWAVES
AT A TIME.
ALSO THE MAGNITUDE.
SO AN IMPORTANT TAKEAWAY AS YOU
LOOK AT
THE STATISTICAL DISTRIBUTION
OF THIS
INFORMATION IS THE MEDIAN
TEMPERATURE
DOESN'T REALLY CHANGE THAT MUCH.
THE MEDIAN GROWS SLOWLY, BUT
THESE EXTREME
EVENTS BECOME MORE MORE
FREQUENT.
AND THE TAILS CONTINUE TO GROW
FURTHER AND FURTHER AWAY.
AND SO FROM A GRID PLANNING
SIDE,
THAT BECOMES A REAL
CHALLENGE BECAUSE YOU'RE HAVING
TO PLAN FOR THOUSANDS
OF MEGAWATTS JUST FOR THOSE
EXTREME EVENTS WHICH ARE,
YOU KNOW, THEREFORE, YOU KNOW,
10 TO 50 HOURS A YEAR.
SO WHAT THE TEN YEAR OUTLOOK
HAS DONE AT THE DIRECTION
OF THE LEGISLATURE WAS TO LOOK
AT, OKAY,
GIVEN THE PROCUREMENT STATUS
WHERE
WE ARE, HOW DOES THAT LOOK,
YOU KNOW, GOING INTO SEVERAL
YEARS FORWARD?
AND, YOU KNOW, MUCH OF THE
NEGATIVES
THAT YOU SEE ON THIS SYSTEM HERE
ARE ALSO BECAUSE SOME OF THESE
YEARS
DON'T HAVE PROCUREMENT AT.
SO THE CPUC WILL BE PUTTING IN
PROCUREMENT.
BUT I THINK DIRECTIONALLY FROM
FROM THE FROM THE AGENCIES,
ALL OUR ANALYSIS SUGGESTS THAT
EVEN IF YOU
MET THE 1 IN 10 LOSS OF LOAD
EXPECTATION,
THERE WILL BE MEGAWATTS THAT
YOU WOULD NEED
BEYOND THAT FOR A VERY, VERY
SHORT TIME.
SO THAT KIND OF PUTS THE
QUESTION ON HOW
DO WE EVOLVE THE STRATEGIC
RESERVE,
THE FUNDING WE CURRENTLY HAVE
IS REALLY
LOOKING AT 2030 TIME FRAME.
AND HERE'S A QUICK VISUAL ON
HOW WE
ARE THINKING ABOUT THAT IN 2023.
UM, YOU KNOW, WE REALLY WERE
TRYING TO STAND UP
A STRATEGIC RESERVE AS QUICKLY
AS WE COULD.
AND SO MUCH OF THAT WAS FOSSIL
BASED,
WHATEVER WE HAD.
WE TOOK IT AND WE RAN WITH IT.
UM, BUT I THINK AS WE MOVE
FORWARD,
WE ARE TRYING TO EVOLVE THAT
TO BE AS CLEAN AS POSSIBLE.
BUT ALSO THE FUNDING STOPS AT
SOME POINT.
AND THEN WE NEED TO THINK ABOUT
HOW HOW
DO WE PLAN FOR THOSE
EMERGENCIES,
YOU KNOW, 2030 AND BEYOND.
SO AS YOU SEE HERE IN 2024 TO
2026,
UM, YOU KNOW, THE OTC, UM,
POWER PLANTS AS DIRECTOR JUST
TALKED ABOUT
REALLY GIVES US A SIGNIFICANT
CUSHION,
ESPECIALLY IN SLOW MOVING
EVENTS.
AND WHAT THAT ALSO GIVES US IS
TIME TO BUILD
THE CLEAN DSGS AND DBA
RESOURCES.
AND THAT'S SOMETHING THAT WE
ARE CONTINUING TO BUILD.
AND ONE OF THE THINGS EVEN
THE DEMAND SIDE GRID SUPPORT
HAD TO RELY ON WAS BACKUP
GENERATION
AND DATA CENTERS.
SO WE ARE HOPING TO REDUCE THAT
AS WE
MOVE FORWARD INTO THE YEARS
HERE,
BECAUSE NOW WE'RE ABLE TO BUILD
THAT VIRTUAL POWER
PLANTS AND THEN DEMAND
FLEXIBILITY OPTIONS.
UM, SO BUT BEYOND 2030 AND AS
THE FUNDING
FOR DWR GOES AWAY IN 2026,
WE WILL HAVE A SIGNIFICANT
REDUCTION
IN OUR STRATEGIC RESERVE.
AND I JUST WANTED TO POINT OUT
THAT'S THE REALITY.
WE ARE GOING TO BE MOVING INTO.
SO THAT KIND OF PROVIDES THE
OVERARCHING
RELIABILITY DISCUSSION.
AND WITH THAT, YOU KNOW, I WOULD
WELCOME PRESIDENT
REYNOLDS BACK TO US ON THE
DISCUSSION OF PATHWAYS.
OKAY.
OUR LAST TOPIC, UM, I WANTED
TO SAY A FEW
WORDS ABOUT THE PATHWAYS
INITIATIVE.
UM, SO JUST A DESCRIPTION OF
THE STATUS OF EFFORTS THAT
ARE UNDERWAY TO INCREASE WEST
WIDE MARKET COORDINATION.
SO THIS IS IN PARALLEL WITH AND
BUILDING
ON KAISER'S DEVELOPMENT OF ITS
MARKET.
UM, AND WHAT WHEN WE SAY
PATHWAYS,
WE'RE REFERRING TO A DIVERSE
GROUP OF STAKEHOLDERS THAT
HAVE FORMED TO EXPLORE FURTHER
EFFORTS TO HARNESS
THE BENEFITS OF A LARGER WESTERN
MARKET.
UM, AND SO I AM GOING TO START
BY TURNING
TO PRESIDENT MAZER, WHO WILL
GIVE,
UM, A REMINDER OF THE BACKGROUND
OF KISSEL'S VARIOUS ROLES.
AND THEN I'LL TALK A LITTLE BIT
MORE ABOUT
THE PATHWAYS INITIATIVE AND HOW
IT BUILDS ON THAT.
THANK YOU, PRESIDENT REYNOLDS.
YEAH, I WANTED JUST TO TO JUST
TO REESTABLISH
GROUNDING IN SORT OF THE KIND
OF DUAL ROLE AND SORT OF
FUNCTIONS THAT
THAT THE CALIFORNIA ISO
PROVIDES.
OF COURSE, FIRST AND FOREMOST,
WE SERVE AS THE, YOU KNOW,
THE BALANCING AUTHORITY FOR
ABOUT 80% OF THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA AND HAVE THE
RESPONSIBILITY
FOR THE DESIGN
AND OVERSIGHT OF THOSE BALANCING
AUTHORITY RULES.
WE OPERATE THE TRANSMISSION
GRID, AS YOU KNOW,
WITHIN THE CAISO FOOTPRINT AND
OF COURSE,
MAINTAIN THE GENERATION
INTERCONNECTION
PROCESS WITHIN OUR FOOTPRINT.
AND ESSENTIALLY THAT THAT THAT
REAL TIME RELIABILITY
RESPONSIBILITY WITHIN THAT,
WITHIN THAT FOOTPRINT.
WE ALSO, OF COURSE, HANDLE
COMPLIANCE WITH
ALL OF THE RELIABILITY STANDARDS
THAT
ARE PROMULGATED BY THE NORTH
AMERICAN
ELECTRIC RELIABILITY
CORPORATION.
SO THOSE ARE SORT OF THE
ESSENTIAL
WITHIN CALIFORNIA FUNCTIONS.
WE ALSO, OF COURSE,
PROVIDE A SET OF REGIONAL
SERVICES.
MORE BROADLY, WE ADMINISTER
THE OVERSIGHT OF THE MARKET
RULES.
OF COURSE, WE HAVE ENTITIES FROM
ACROSS THE WESTERN UNITED
STATES WHO PARTICIPATE IN OUR
EXISTING ENERGY MARKETS.
WE PROVIDE PHYSICAL OPERATION
AND OPTIMIZATION
OF A REGIONAL DISPATCH.
WE ARE RESPONSIBLE FOR THE
SETTLEMENT OF
ALL THE DIFFERENT MARKET
TRANSACTIONS.
AND OF COURSE, WE ALSO SERVE AS
THE RELIABILITY COORDINATOR
FOR ABOUT 80% OF THE WESTERN
WEST UNITED STATES.
THIS IS A FUNCTION THAT WE
TOOK ON SEVERAL YEARS AGO.
SORT OF THINK OF US AS KIND
OF A CONTROL TOWER OPERATOR
FOR EVEN A BIGGER FOOTPRINT
OUTSIDE OF CALIFORNIA,
AND THESE ARE SERVICES THAT
WE'VE OPERATED
FOR FOR A NUMBER OF YEARS,
IN PARALLEL WITH OUR CORE
RESPONSIBILITIES
TO THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
TURNING TO THE NEXT SLIDE.
I WANTED TO JUST TOUCH BRIEFLY
ON
THE WESTERN ENERGY IMBALANCE
MARKET,
WHICH IN MANY WAYS HAS BEEN
SORT OF
THE FOUNDATION STONE AND SET OFF
THE BROADER DIALOGUE AROUND
REGIONAL
COORDINATION IN RECENT YEARS.
THE WESTERN ENERGY IMBALANCE
MARKET
IS EFFECTIVELY A REAL TIME,
SHORT TERM ENERGY MARKET THAT
ALLOWS PARTICIPANTS TO BUY
AND SELL AVAILABLE ENERGY IN
A VERY SHORT TERM BASIS.
AND SINCE 2014, THIS ENERGY
MARKET
HAS GENERATED ROUGHLY $5.85
BILLION IN GROSS BENEFITS FOR
CUSTOMERS,
WITH A SIGNIFICANT FRACTION OF
THAT GOING HERE
TO CALIFORNIA ELECTRICITY
RATEPAYERS.
WE ARE NOW IN THE PROCESS OF
ENABLING OUR AIM
PARTICIPANTS TO BUY AND SELL
ENERGY IN
THE DAY AHEAD TIME FRAME THROUGH
WHAT IS
KNOWN AS OUR EXTENDED DAY AHEAD
MARKET,
OR EDAM, AND THE DAY AHEAD
MARKET WILL ALLOW FOR EVEN
FURTHER OPTIMIZATION OF
ECONOMICS AND RELIABILITY,
AND AN EVEN GREATER,
BROADER FOOTPRINT OF
COLLABORATION.
THIS MARKET STRUCTURE, I THINK
MANY FOLKS WOULD SAY,
IS THE NEXT LOGICAL STEP IN
ENHANCING
REGIONAL MARKETS AND ACHIEVING
EVEN GREATER
ECONOMIC AND RELIABILITY
BENEFITS.
SO I'M GOING TO TURN IT BACK
TO PRESIDENT
REYNOLDS WITH SOME ADDITIONAL
COMMENTS.
OKAY, GREAT.
UM, SO WHAT WE WANTED TO TALK
ABOUT A LITTLE
BIT IS EXPLORATION OF A LARGER
MARKET.
SO COMPARED TO THE EFFORTS THAT
PRESIDENT
MAJOR MEINZER DESCRIBED
THAT WE'RE ALREADY SEEING
BENEFITS FROM THE AIM.
AND KYSO HAS DEVELOPED A TARIFF
FOR
AN ENHANCED DAY-AHEAD MARKET.
BUT THERE'S AN ALSO AN EFFORT
UNDERWAY TO
EXAMINE PROPOSALS FOR AN
INDEPENDENT
REGIONAL ORGANIZATION THAT WOULD
GOVERN THE MARKET FUNCTIONS,
NOT THE OTHER KIND OF FUNCTIONS,
BUT THE MARKET THAT WOULD
LEVERAGE
THE EXISTING KAIZO
INFRASTRUCTURE
AND MINIMIZE COST TO RATEPAYERS.
SO RECALL THE THREE LARGE GRIDS
IN THE THE US,
THE WESTERN AND THE EASTERN
TEXAS.
SO WE'RE ALREADY CONNECTED TO
THE WEST, INCLUDING CANADA.
BUT THE MARKETS AND THE MARKET
OPERATIONS
IN THE WEST ARE VERY FRAGMENTED.
WE HAVE A LARGE NUMBER OF
BALANCING AUTHORITIES
AND WE HAVE THE KAIZO MARKET,
AND THEN WE HAVE BILATERAL
TRADING AND WE HAVE.
AND SO THIS EFFORT IS REALLY
THINKING ABOUT
THE BENEFITS OF A LARGER MARKET.
MEANING THINK ABOUT A MARKET
WITH A FOOTPRINT
THAT IS LARGER THAN ANY ONE
WEATHER EVENT.
SO WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THE
RESOURCES
IN CALIFORNIA THAT NEED TO
TO BE READY FOR CALIFORNIA FOR
ONLY
10 TO 20 DAYS OF THE YEAR.
AND WITH THE SHARED MARKET, WE
CAN OPTIMIZE
THOSE RESOURCES FOR RELIABILITY
PURPOSES,
WORK WITH OUR NEIGHBORS.
SO IT'S HOT IN ARIZONA, AND
THOSE
RESOURCES CAN GO THERE.
IT'S HOT IN CALIFORNIA.
WE CAN DRAW FROM THE PACIFIC
NORTHWEST.
AND AS I SAID, WE'RE CONNECTED.
BUT A MARKET WOULD ABLE WOULD
ENABLE
US TO DO THAT MORE EFFECTIVELY.
IT WOULD PROVIDE VISIBILITY FOR
OPERATIONAL
PURPOSES INTO A WIDER RANGE
OF RESOURCES FOR RELIABILITY
PURPOSES,
BUT ALSO FOR COST BENEFITS.
AND SO THE IDEA WOULD BE THESE
SHARED
RESOURCES COULD MAXIMISE
THE COST SAVINGS FOR RATEPAYERS,
REALLY THROUGHOUT THE WEST.
AND SO WE SHARE SOME INTERESTS
OF OUR
WESTERN PARTNERS IN INCREASING
RELIABILITY AND DECREASING
COSTS THROUGHOUT THE WEST.
UM, AND IMPORTANTLY, THE THE
CHANGES THAT
ARE BEING ARE BEING DISCUSSED IN
THE PATHWAYS INITIATIVE WOULD
NOT INVOLVE
CHANGES TO THE BALANCING
AUTHORITY.
UM, THE CONCEPTS THAT ARE
EXPLORED
REALLY TAKE INTO ACCOUNT
KAISO REMAINING AS KAISO FOR
BALANCING
AUTHORITY PURPOSES,
AS WELL AS OUR OWN TRANSMISSION
PLANNING
THAT WE DO FOR CALIFORNIA.
AND SO THAT IS OUR JOINT AGENCY
PLANNING EXERCISE THAT
WE'VE BEEN TALKING ABOUT HERE
TODAY WITH ANY OF
THE PROPOSALS THAT THE PATHWAYS
INITIATIVE IS TALKING ABOUT,
KAISER WOULD RETAIN THOSE
FUNCTIONS.
UM, THE PATHWAYS INITIATIVE IS
WAS FORMED,
AS I SAID, BY A GROUP OF
STAKEHOLDERS,
AND IT'S REALLY INTERESTED
PARTIES
THROUGHOUT THE WEST
INVOLVING STAKEHOLDERS FROM UM,
UH, A LARGE GROUP,
NUMBER OF GROUPS, CUSTOMERS,
LARGE AND SMALL CUSTOMERS,
CONSUMER GROUPS, LABOR,
ENVIRONMENTAL GROUPS,
THE INVESTOR OWNED UTILITIES,
THE PUBLIC POWER,
UM, UH, INDEPENDENT POWER
PRODUCERS.
SO REALLY, A BROAD GROUP OF
STAKEHOLDERS
WHO ARE WORKING
ON EXPLORING OPTIONS FOR
ADDITIONAL COOPERATION.
UM, LET ME NOW TURN TO A CHAIR
FOR VICE CHAIR GUNDA.
UM, THANK YOU.
PRESIDENT.
SO KIND OF, UM, I THINK CHAIR
BRADFORD,
YOU KIND OF SET THAT UP.
UH, REALLY?
WELL, I THINK WITHIN THE, UM,
RESOURCE BOARD'S,
UH, KIND OF MANDATE,
YOU KNOW, THEY, THEY KIND OF
HAVE BEEN TAKING,
DIFFERENT STEPS TO ENHANCE
THE MARKET AS THEY SEE FROM
I'M TO
NOW IDEM SO WHAT THE PATHWAYS
INITIATIVE
OF THIS INDEPENDENT,
WEST WIDE, SELF-ORGANIZED GROUP
OF STAKEHOLDERS,
ALONG WITH THE,
WITH THE STATE REPRESENTATIVES
IS REALLY LOOKING
AT WHAT ARE THEIR SUGGESTIONS
FOR
THE KAISER BOARD TO CONSIDER
TO CONTINUE
TO ENHANCE THOSE MARKET
FUNCTIONS?
SO WITH THAT, THEY, YOU KNOW,
IT'S A GOOD TIME.
THEY JUST SET UP A STEP ONE UM,
OF ASK TO THE TO THE KAISER.
THEY'VE PUT SOME PROPOSALS, BUT
THE PROPOSAL
REALLY FOCUSES ON CONTINUING
TO CREATE CONDITIONS TO CAPTURE
THE BROADEST FOOTPRINT UNDER
EDAM.
SO AND AND IN ORDER TO CAPTURE
THE BROADEST FOOTPRINT
AGAIN TO TO PRESENT REYNOLDS'S
POINT,
IT'S BOTH ABOUT AFFORDABILITY
BUT ALSO RELIABILITY
TO ENSURING THAT SEAMLESS
EXCHANGE OF ENERGY.
AND SO THE PROPOSAL IN FRONT IS
TO DEVELOP FURTHER INDEPENDENCE
ON JUST THE GOVERNANCE OF THE
MARKET FUNCTIONS.
SO AND THEN BECOMING MORE, UM,
A MARKET GOVERNED BY THE BROADER
WESTERN UM GROUPS TO ALLOW FOR
THOSE CONDITIONS NECESSARY TO
HAVE MORE PEOPLE FEEL
CONFIDENT AND COMFORTABLE TO
JOIN THE EDM.
SO THAT'S THE STEP ONE PROPOSAL,
AND THE KAISER BOARD
IS CURRENTLY CONSIDERING THAT
STEP ONE PROPOSAL
RIGHT NOW TO AND WILL VOTE ON
IT AS SOON HERE,
AND I'LL SHARE THAT IN THE NEXT
SLIDE.
BUT, YOU KNOW, JUST IN THE
GOVERNANCE
FRAMEWORK IN THE LAST BULLET
POINT,
I JUST WANTED TO RAISE A FEW
THINGS.
SO ONE.
CURRENTLY WE HAVE TWO BOARDS.
WE HAVE THE KAISER BOARD AND
THEN WESTERN
ENERGY IMBALANCE MARKET BOARD.
BOTH OPERATE AT KAISER.
AND THE WESTERN ENERGY IMBALANCE
BOARD IS LOOKING AT
THE MARKET RULES AND THEN
THEY'RE
HELPING THEM DEVELOP.
AND ONCE THOSE MARKET RULES ARE
DEVELOPED,
THEY COME TO THE KAISER BOARD
FOR FINALLY
BEING ABLE TO VOTE ON THEM.
WHAT THE PROPOSAL, YOU KNOW,
ASKS FOR IS THAT THE MARKET
RULED
ARE REALLY DECIDED UNDER THE
WHEAT BOARD PRIMARILY.
AND THEN, YOU KNOW,
THE SAME WITH WHAT WE HAVE
TODAY.
THERE WILL BE A DISPUTE
RESOLUTION
IF THE BOARDS DON'T AGREE.
BUT WHAT WHAT YOU SEE ON THE
THIRD ONE, UM.
UM, AT THE SECOND ONE IS
IMPORTANT,
WHICH IS IF THE DISPUTE
RESOLUTION DID NOT BRING THE TWO
BOARDS TOGETHER,
THERE IS A JUMP BALL FILING
TO FERC,
MEANING BOTH BOARDS CAN PUT
THEIR PROPOSAL TO FERC.
AND JUST KIND OF NOTING THAT
KAISER TODAY, YOU KNOW,
IS IT WORKS UNDER THE FERC
PUBLIC UTILITY AUTHORITY.
AND SO THERE'LL BE FILED THERE.
AND THEN THERE'LL BE, YOU KNOW,
BOTH YOU KNOW,
THE THE WESTERN STAKEHOLDERS
FEEL THAT'S A FAIR
THING FOR FERC TO HEAR THEIR
CONCERNS.
BUT KAISER BOARD RETAINS SOLE
FOR FILINGS,
WILL CONTINUE TO RETAIN THAT
AND ALSO HAVE
RETENTION ON THE EXIGENT
CIRCUMSTANCES.
AND FINALLY, PUBLIC INTEREST WAS
ADDED AND NO THANKS TO PRESIDENT
REYNOLDS AND MANY OF THE
REGULATORS IN THE WEST.
THE OUIJA BOARD AND THE WESTERN
ENERGY
IMBALANCE MARKET BOARD DOESN'T
CURRENTLY HAVE WITHIN THEIR
STATUTE
A PUBLIC INTEREST COMPONENT.
AND THAT WAS ADDED IN THE
PROPOSAL
THAT THAT HAS TO BE HONOURED,
GIVEN THAT THIS ENHANCED ROLE
AND FINALLY,
THIS PROPOSAL WILL NOT TRIGGER
UNLESS THERE
IS A 70% OF KAIZO CURRENT DAM
LOAD.
JOINING THE DAM.
SO THOSE ARE SEVERAL TRIGGER
POINTS.
SO THAT'S THE ASK RIGHT NOW IN
FRONT OF
THE KAISER BOARD AND GOING INTO
THE NEXT STEPS.
UM, YOU KNOW, ON JUNE 5TH, THE
LAUNCH COMMITTEE
SUBMITTED THIS PROPOSAL TO THE
KAISER BOARD.
WE ANTICIPATE THE KAISER BOARD
TO BE VOTING ON THIS SOON.
UM, AT A, UM, IN AUGUST, AT A
JOINT BOARD MEETING,
BOTH THE VM BOARD AND THE KAISER
BOARD,
AND FROM JULY THROUGH AUGUST,
UH,
IN THE PATHWAYS INITIATIVE,
THEY'RE HOLDING A NUMBER OF
PUBLIC
WORKSHOPS TO CONTINUE TO
THINK ABOUT WHAT MORE CAN BE
DONE ON THE MARKET FRONT,
SO WE CAN PUSH THE MARKETS EVEN
FURTHER
IN THE WEST AND EVOLVE THEM.
SO BETWEEN SEPTEMBER AND
DECEMBER,
WHAT WE ANTICIPATE IS THAT
THE PATHWAYS LAUNCH COMMITTEE
WILL PREPARE AND DRAFT A,
YOU KNOW, DRAFT AN ISSUE OF
FINAL PROPOSAL
ON THE NEXT STEPS OF EVOLVING
THIS.
SO WE HAVE STEP ONE PROPOSAL
AND THEY'LL
COME UP WITH FURTHER STEP TWO,
OUR NEXT STEPS ON HOW TO EVOLVE
THESE MARKETS AS A PROPOSAL.
SO RIGHT NOW AGAIN IN CLOSING,
YOU KNOW,
THIS IS A SELF-ORGANIZED
STAKEHOLDER GROUP THAT HAS,
YOU KNOW,
CONTINUED TO THINK THROUGH THE
PROBLEM STATEMENT
OF HOW DO WE, UM, HAVE THE
BROADEST,
UM, YOU KNOW, FOOTPRINT OF
ENERGY MARKETS
SO IT COULD BENEFIT THE WEST.
AND, YOU KNOW, BASED ON THOSE
DISCUSSIONS,
AN INITIAL PROPOSAL HAS COME
THROUGH
WHICH IS IN FRONT OF THE KAISER.
AND THE KAISER IS RIGHT NOW
DECIDING ON THAT.
SO THAT'S ALL WE HAVE IN
PREPARED SLIDES.
AND SO THAT WILL WILL STOP AND
TAKE YOUR QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR THAT PRESENTATION.
MUCH APPRECIATED.
AND I'LL JUST TURN IT TO MY
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
OR ARE THERE ANY QUESTIONS THAT
COMMITTEE
MEMBERS HAVE A FEW THINGS.
>> OKAY I'LL DO FIRST IF YOU
WANT TO GO.
GO AHEAD IF YOU'RE READY.
ALL RIGHT.
SURE.
YEAH.
THANKS.
>> THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIR.
AND THANK YOU TO OUR PRESIDENTS
AND, UH, VICE CHAIR.
UM, I THINK THIS KIND OF JOINT
RELIABILITY
PLANNING IS EXACTLY WHAT WE HAD
IN MIND.
UM, WHEN WE INITIATED ALL THIS,
UM,
AND THIS KIND OF QUARTERLY
UPDATE IS VERY HELPFUL
AND ENCOURAGING TO SEE ALL THE
COORDINATION
ACROSS JURISDICTIONS HERE.
UM, I KNOW WE'VE BEEN OPERATING
IN,
I WOULDN'T SAY COMPLETELY LUCKY
CIRCUMSTANCES,
BUT A RELATIVELY WET YEAR OR
WET YEARS,
RELATIVELY LOW FIRE SEASONS.
UM, IT'S ALL HELD UP UNDER THESE
CIRCUMSTANCES,
BUT WE HAVEN'T HAD THE KIND OF
2022 CONDITIONS,
AS YOU ALL NOTED.
SO STILL CAUTIOUS AS I
APPRECIATE
YOU ALL ARE AS WELL.
UM, MY QUESTIONS WERE REALLY
ABOUT
SORT OF THE LOOK FORWARD
IN THAT POST 26 OR 26 AND BEYOND
TIME FRAME AND HOW TO, UM,
HOW TO MAKE SURE WE'RE GETTING
THE MOST
BANG FOR OUR BUCK IN THIS KIND
OF STRATEGIC RESERVE CONTRACTING
THAT WE'VE BEEN UNDERTAKING.
MY UNDERSTANDING FROM THE
INTERACTIONS
WITH THE BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE
CHAIR AND OUR STAFF ON THE ON
THE CURRENT CONTRACT FOR THE
OTCS,
UM, IS THAT OF THE 1.2 BILLION
WHICH, UM,
IF I MISS HO UH, IS ALL GENERAL
FUND FUNDED, RIGHT.
THAT 1.2.
RIGHT.
UM, THAT, UH, THAT ONLY A
CERTAIN AMOUNT
HAS ACTUALLY BEEN SPENT DOWN,
BUT THAT, UM, THE BULK OF IT
REMAINS SORT OF UNSPENT.
CAN YOU DISTINGUISH FOR US JUST
HOW MUCH
HAS BEEN INVESTED FROM THAT $1.2
BILLION CONTRACT IN, UM,
UPGRADES AND RETROFITS AND SORT
OF SUNK COSTS,
LIKE PHYSICAL ASSET UPGRADES
VERSUS
THAT SORT OF INSURANCE POLICY
OR THE CAPACITY THAT WE'VE
PURCHASED,
IN OTHER WORDS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
QUESTION, SENATOR.
YES, I'D BE HAPPY TO TALK ABOUT
THAT.
SO ONE THING I DO WANT TO
DIFFERENTIATE IS,
UM, EXACTLY HOW YOU DESCRIBED.
THERE'S A COUPLE DIFFERENT
CATEGORIES THAT WE WERE
CONTEMPLATING WHEN WE SIGNED
THESE CONTRACTS.
BUT I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO
FOCUS ON THE OVERALL.
SO AS WE ALL KNOW, THESE ONCE
THROUGH
COOLING RESOURCES WOULD HAVE
RETIRED.
BUT FOR THESE CONTRACTS AND OF
COURSE,
THAT WAS ALSO THE AGREEMENT THAT
WE HAD
WITH THE STATE WATER RESOURCES
CONTROL BOARD
IN ORDER TO EXTEND THEIR
PERMITS.
SO THERE'S A COUPLE OF THINGS
AT PLAY.
SO OBVIOUSLY FOR THE RESERVE, WE
DO WANT TO MAINTAIN
THE PHYSICAL CAPACITY OF THE
RESOURCES.
BUT WHAT'S ALSO VERY CRITICAL
IS HAVING
THE STAFFING AND THE COMMITMENT
TO BE
ABLE TO OPERATE THESE FACILITIES
AND TO HAVE THEM STAFFED 24 OVER
SEVEN.
SO THERE'S THE CONTRACTS THAT
YOU
SEE AND THE COMMITMENT THERE IS
THE PAYMENT IS STRUCTURED AS
SIMILAR
AS POSSIBLE TO WHAT FOLKS
HAVE KNOWN AND GOTTEN USED TO
IN SORT
OF THE RESOURCE ADEQUACY
CONSTRUCT,
WHICH IS THERE, STRUCTURED AS
MONTH TO MONTH PAYMENTS.
BUT OVERALL, THE CONTRACT IS
FOR A TOTAL OF THREE YEARS
FROM JANUARY 24TH THROUGH
DECEMBER 31ST, 2026.
SO AS THE UNITS PERFORM, UM,
WE PAY OUT MONTH TO MONTH THAT
CAPACITY PAYMENT.
THERE'S ALSO A COMPONENT WHERE
WE DO PROVIDE
FUNDING IN ORDER FOR THEM TO GO
THROUGH MAINTENANCE TO DO THEIR
TO DO
UPGRADES THAT THE DWR WOULD
APPROVE,
AND TO MAKE SURE THAT THE UNITS
ARE READY AND AVAILABLE
TO RESPOND TO CALIFORNIA ISO
DISPATCH.
SO IT'S IMPORTANT TO THINK OF
THE CONTRACT AS A WHOLE,
AND THAT THE THE NEGOTIATION
WITH
THE COUNTERPARTY WAS, UM,
CONTINGENT ON HAVING THE ALL
THREE YEAR
CONTRACT AND THE VISIBILITY OF
ALL OF THOSE ASPECTS COMBINED
TOGETHER
AS PART OF THAT NEGOTIATION.
GREAT.
SO I APPRECIATE THAT.
THAT'S WHY I DESCRIBED MY
QUESTION THAT WAY.
SO I'M ASKING HOW MUCH YOU'VE
SPENT
ON UPGRADING LIKE AUMONT.
HOW MUCH HAVE YOU SPENT ON I
UNDERSTAND
THEY WERE GOING TO
TAKE A CHUNK OF THE MONEY
AND RIP OUT THE POWERHOUSE,
BUILD A WHOLE NEW CRANE AND
UPGRADE THAT OTC THAT
WAS SCHEDULED FOR TAKE BEING
TAKEN OFFLINE.
SO HOW MUCH HAVE WE SPENT TO
THE CONTRACTS
ON UPGRADING ORMOND, FOR
INSTANCE?
OH, WE.
CAN DEFINITELY GET THOSE NUMBERS
FOR YOU.
BUT I THINK IN THAT SPECIFIC
QUESTION THAT YOU'RE ASKING,
I'M NOT AWARE THAT THAT HAS
HAPPENED.
THE FUNDING THAT DWR HAS
PROVIDED IS
TO BE ABLE TO MAINTAIN THE
RESOURCE
IN ITS CURRENT OPERATION IN
ORDER
TO RESPOND TO THE CASE.
SO I'M NOT ENTIRELY SURE IF WHAT
YOU'RE ASKING
FOR IS MAYBE A FUTURE
DEVELOPMENT FOR FOR.
I UNDERSTAND IT UNDERSTANDING
WAS TO MAKE THAT
THAT RESOURCE EVEN AVAILABLE
TO THE GRID,
THAT MAJOR OVERHAULS WERE GOING
TO HAVE TO
BE SUNK INTO IT TO GET IT
OPERATIONAL.
SO I'M JUST TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT,
I GET THAT YOU'RE OBLIGATED
IN THE CAPACITY PAYMENTS.
I GET THE STRUCTURE OF THE
CONTRACT.
I'M ASKING ABOUT HOW MUCH HAS
BEEN SPENT
ON THE PHYSICAL ASSET TO GET
A SENSE
OF HOW MUCH WE'RE ON THE HOOK
FOR,
FOR SPENDING TO UPGRADE THESE
UNITS.
AND IF WE SHOULD ANTICIPATE YOU
ALL ASKING FOR
ANOTHER EXTENSION POST 26,
BECAUSE, SAY,
WE'VE SPENT $300 MILLION OF
TAXPAYERS
MONEY ON UPGRADING
AN OLD GAS PLANT AND MAKING IT
NEW AGAIN,
AND ARE WE JUST GOING TO WALK
AWAY FROM THAT ASSET?
ARE WE GOING TO KEEP GOING WITH
IT?
SO WHEN YOU SAY WE'VE SEEN THE
CONTRACTS,
WE WE HAVEN'T SEEN THE
CONTRACTS.
UM, YOU HAVE THE CONTRACTS,
BUT WE'VE
ASKED QUESTIONS ABOUT THEM.
YOU'VE GIVEN US RESPONSES.
AND I GET THE DEFENSE OF THE OF
THE STRUCTURE AND ALL THAT.
BUT EVEN JUST TO SEE THE TERMS
OF THE CONTRACT OR UNDERSTAND
THESE AND REALLY DO INCLUDE THAT
IN THE GPA,
OR AT LEAST AN UPDATE ON 205,
I THINK WOULD BE REALLY HELPFUL.
UM, SO YOU'RE SAYING YOU DON'T
HAVE
THAT INFORMATION TODAY THOUGH?
HOW MUCH?
NOT TODAY.
BUT HAPPY TO PROVIDE THAT TO
YOU, SIR.
WE CAN DEFINITELY PROVIDE THE
CONTRACTS AS WELL.
UM, AND JUST TO MAKE CLEAR,
OUR GOAL IS TO MAINTAIN THE
FACILITIES,
NOT TO MAKE THEM, LIKE, NEW.
SO, SURE, WE'RE ON THE SAME PAGE
THERE.
I GUESS JUST TO FINISH UP THAT
LINE OF QUESTIONING.
AND THANKS, MR.
CHAIR.
UM, UH, MY UNDERSTANDING IS THAT
WE CANNOT THERE'S
NO REVERSION CLAUSE AND THAT WE
CAN'T ACTUALLY,
UM, IF WE SAY WE'VE ONLY SPENT
$300 MILLION OF IT,
A $1.2 BILLION CONTRACT,
WE CAN'T GO TAKE THE OUTSTANDING
900 MILLION AND DIVERT THAT
TO SAY,
TA TA ASSETS THAT WE'RE ACTUALLY
GOING TO UTILIZE.
THAT'S MY UNDERSTANDING OF
THE TERMS OF THE CONTRACT,
IS THAT IT CAN'T BE ALTERED FOR
THE SORT OF THE UNSPENT FUNDS.
IS THAT IS THAT RIGHT?
UM, SO IT I WANT TO MAYBE MAKE
A SLIGHT MODIFICATION TO THAT.
SO THE AMOUNTS THAT WE HAVE
COMMITTED
ARE MAXIMUM COMMITMENT AMOUNTS,
AND IT'S TO COVER CONTINGENCIES
THAT WE SEE AND CONDITIONS
THAT WE SEE PURSUANT TO THE, TO
THE CONTRACT.
BUT TO THE EXTENT THOSE FUNDS
ARE NOT SPENT, FOR EXAMPLE,
BECAUSE THERE ARE PROVISIONS,
FOR EXAMPLE,
FOR IF THE NOT EVERY CONTRACT
BUT SOME
OF THE CONTRACTS, FOR EXAMPLE,
HAVE BOTH PENALTY AND
PERFORMANCE PROVISIONS.
SO IF THEY PERFORM WELL,
THEY CAN EARN SOME ADDITIONAL
FUNDS.
IF THEY DON'T, THEY CAN GET
PENALIZED.
SO DEPENDING ON HOW THAT UH.
UNDERSTOOD.
BUT IF THEY DON'T PERFORM AT
ALL,
WHICH IS CURRENTLY WHAT THEY'RE
DOING.
RIGHT.
THEY, WE HAVE NOT UTILIZED ANY
OF
THE OTCS TO MEET ANY OF THESE
EVENTS.
IS THAT CORRECT?
WE'VE USED.
BUT AGAIN, DO YOU WANT TO BE
CAREFUL.
THAT THEY'RE ON CAPACITY?
I GET THAT THEY'RE ON RESERVE.
WE'VE PAID FOR THE RESERVE, BUT
WE HAVE NOT ACTUALLY
RUN THOSE OTCS UNDER THESE
CONTRACTS
TO MEET ANY OF THE GRID
RELIABILITY EVENTS
THAT ISO IS REFERRING TO, RIGHT?
THE NUMBER WAS ZERO,
AT LEAST IN THE CHART OF HOW
MUCH
THEY'VE ACTUALLY BEEN UTILIZED,
LIKE TURNED ON.
HAVE THEY BEEN TURNED ON AT ALL
TO ME?
THEY'VE BEEN.
ON STANDBY IN CASE I GOT.
AN EMERGENCY STANDBY.
I GET I'M SAYING HAVE THEY BEEN
RUN.
NOT NOT TO ITS MAXIMUM.
NOT TO ITS MAXIMUM CAPACITY.
THAT'S CORRECT.
OKAY.
SO SO THOSE ARE SORT OF SITTING
ON LAYAWAY.
WE'VE PUT OVER $1 BILLION INTO
THEM.
WE DON'T WE'RE GOING TO FIND
OUT HOW
MUCH WE'VE ACTUALLY SPENT ON
THAT.
MEANWHILE THE ASSETS THAT HAVE
KEPT THE GRID SOLID,
WHAT I'VE HEARD IS A HUGE
INCREASE IN STORAGE,
A GREAT PERFORMANCE OUT OF WHAT
WE'VE GOT AT DSGS SO FAR.
FURTHER LOOKING AT THE DSG'S.
UH, AND THAT KIND OF DEMAND SIDE
WORK FROM ISO.
UM, BUT WE'VE ONLY SPENT I THINK
MY MATH IS HERE,
ABOUT 18% OF THE FUNDS THAT HAVE
BEEN APPROPRIATED
ON DBA AND DSG'S THUS FAR.
IF YOU COMBINE BOTH, I THINK
IT'S ABOUT 540
MILLION AND WE'VE ONLY SPENT
A COMBINED.
WHATEVER.
YOU GET THE NUMBERS.
UM, I KNOW THIS YEAR IN THE
BUDGET WE MOVED
THAT FROM GENERAL FUND TO THE
GRF.
I'M REALLY HAPPY THAT WE'RE
AT LEAST
KEEPING THE MONEY MOVING,
BUT I'M FRUSTRATED WITH THE PACE
OF THINGS, AND I.
I SEE YOUR CHART ANTICIPATES
GROWTH IN INCREASE.
UM, THE CONCERN IS AT THE SAME
TIME
YOU'RE ANTICIPATING THIS GROWTH
AND THINGS COMING ONLINE AND
US HITTING
HIGHER NUMBERS IN 25, 26.
MEANWHILE, EDISON'S PLAN ON VP'S
AND DEMAND
SIDE WORK WAS REJECTED AT THE
PUC IN PART.
DWP HAS PULLED BACK, SO I'M JUST
TRYING
TO WRESTLE WITH AND I GET THAT
THAT'S
A RATEPAYER FUNDED APPLICATION
VERSUS
A GRF NON RATE BASED FUNDED.
BUT SHOULD WHAT KIND OF
TAKEAWAYS
SHOULD WE BE DERIVING
FROM THAT SORT OF THE
UNDERUTILIZATION,
I GUESS, OF THE APPROPRIATED
DOLLARS?
AND WHAT ARE WE GOING TO SEE A
RAMP HERE SOON?
UM, AND A AND A SORT OF
ENGAGEMENT
WITH UTILITIES ON THIS FRONT,
OR IS THERE STILL A,
I GUESS A DISCORDANCE LIKE,
OKAY,
YES, WE'LL SPEND GRF ON IT,
BUT NO,
WE'RE NOT REALLY GOING TO
ENCOURAGE
THE UTILITIES TO KEEP GOING
WITH IT.
MAYBE BETWEEN CEC AND PUC YOU
COULD COMMENT.
I KNOW THERE'S SORT OF TWO
DIFFERENT
SOURCES OF FUNDS,
SO TWO DIFFERENT SETS OF
SENSITIVITIES TO.
BUT YEAH, I'LL START WITH THE
RATEPAYER ASPECT.
AND UM, I THINK MAYBE THE MOST
IMPORTANT
THING TO THINK ABOUT IS THAT
WE HAVE A RANGE OF THESE TYPES
OF VPPS
AND DEMAND RESPONSE PROGRAMS.
WE'RE DOING PILOTS.
WE HAVE EXISTING PROGRAMS THAT
HAVE
BEEN IN EFFECT FOR QUITE SOME
TIME.
WE HAVE REGULAR RA PROGRAMS.
PROGRAMS DEMAND RESPONSE
PROGRAMS
THAT QUALIFY FOR RA,
AND WE HAVE EMERGENCY PROGRAMS.
AND SO WHAT WE'RE LOOKING AT IS
REALLY KIND OF
BRINGING FORWARD LOTS OF TYPES
OF CREATIVITY,
BUT ALSO BEING VERY CAREFUL AS
A STEWARD OF RATEPAYER FUNDS,
THESE FUNDS ALL SHOW UP ON
ELECTRICITY BILLS.
AND AND THEN GIVEN THE, THE THE
UNCERTAINTIES
THAT WE HAVE MOVING FORWARD,
WE'RE KIND OF DESIGNING TO
ADDRESS
THOSE UNCERTAINTIES,
BUT MAKING SURE THAT THE
PROGRAMS
CONTINUE TO FIT WHAT WE SEE
AND ANTICIPATE AND GET THE MOST
BANG
FOR OUR BUCK FROM RATEPAYERS.
AND SO AS WE AND I THINK
THE UTILITIES ARE AND THE CCAS
IN PARTICULAR ARE BEING VERY
RESPONSIVE AND CREATIVE.
UM, BUT WHEN WE COMPARE ACROSS
A WHOLE PORTFOLIO OF PROGRAMS,
NOT WE'RE GOING TO WANT TO FOCUS
ON THE MOST COST EFFECTIVE
ONES AND KEEP KIND OF DRIVING
TOWARDS THOSE.
AND SO THAT DOESN'T MEAN THAT
WE ALLOW
RATEPAYERS MONEY TO BE SPENT
ON EVERYTHING EVERYBODY WANTS
TO DO, NO MATTER THE COST.
AND SO WE REALLY ARE SEEING A
GREAT UPTAKE.
WE'RE LEARNING A LOT ABOUT VGI,
WE'RE LEARNING A LOT ABOUT VPPS.
AND THEN WE'RE ALSO OF COURSE,
DOING THE LARGER
KIND OF MEGAWATT PROGRAMS AS
WE GO.
SO.
UM, SENATOR STERN, I THINK JUST
THANK YOU FOR THAT QUESTION.
UM, I JUST WANT TO ADD KIND OF
A LITTLE BIT OF COLOR TO WHAT,
UM, PRESIDENT DONALD JUST
MENTIONED.
UM, AS YOU KNOW, LIKE ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT YOU
ASKED THE CEC TO DO WAS THE LOAD
FLEX GOAL.
UM, SO AS A PART OF THE GOAL,
UM, YOU KNOW,
WE'VE SET A 7000 MEGAWATT GOAL
STATEWIDE
AND BY THE END OF 2030 AND WE
REALLY,
YOU KNOW, CATEGORIZED THEM INTO
THREE BUCKETS.
RIGHT.
SO THE THE FIRST BUCKET WAS
AROUND THE LOAD MODIFYING.
SO HOW DO YOU MAKE SURE THAT THE
RATE DESIGN, UM,
REALLY ENHANCES OUR ABILITY TO
FLEX DEMAND.
AND I THINK THAT'S THERE'S A
NUMBER OF STEPS
THAT ARE BEING TAKEN THERE AND
THROUGH
PWC'S KAFKA'S PROCEEDING AND
CCI'S WORK
ON THE LOAD MANAGEMENT
STANDARDS,
AND THERE'S AN OPPORTUNITY TO
REALLY THINK
ABOUT HOW DO YOU EXTEND THAT
WEDGE.
THAT'S THE FIRST PART.
THE SECOND PART, I THINK, IS,
YOU KNOW,
KIND OF THE REGULAR RESOURCE
ADEQUACY,
WHICH WE CALL THE PROXY PLANNING
TODAY.
AND, YOU KNOW, HOW DO YOU SEE
THAT WEDGE MOVING FORWARD,
ESPECIALLY GIVEN THE NUMBER OF
THINGS THAT ARE HAPPENING
THROUGH MORE AND MORE GADGETS
WE HAVE TODAY.
RIGHT?
SO LIKE, IS IT A GADGET BACKED
OR IS IT BEHAVIORAL
PROGRAM AND HOW DO THEY EVOLVE.
AND THE THIRD BUCKET IS
THE IS THE EMERGENCY PROGRAMS.
SO WHAT THE UM, YOU KNOW,
THE FUNDING THROUGH THE DSGS
AND DBA HAS
GIVEN US IS AN OPPORTUNITY TO
TEST
NEW CONCEPTS OF PROGRAM DESIGN.
AND I THINK ONE OF THE THINGS
WE ARE DOING
IS WE'RE WORKING VERY CLOSELY
WITH PUC.
ON TO THE EXTENT THAT THESE
PROGRAMS ARE
VIABLE IN TERMS OF COST
EFFECTIVE,
THEY CAN KIND OF MIGRATE INTO
THE MIDDLE WEDGE, RIGHT?
SO WHICH IS KIND OF MORE ON THE
RADAR SIDE.
BUT THE YOU KNOW, RIGHT NOW
IN A IN
BASED ON THE LEGISLATURE'S ASK,
WE REALLY ARE FOCUSING ON THAT
VP
BUCKET WHICH IS MARKET AWARE.
RIGHT.
IT'S NOT DISPATCHED BY CAISO.
BUT IN THE DAY AHEAD TIME FRAME
IF THE PRICES MEET A $200,
THEY BEGIN TO DISPATCH AND
SUPPORT.
AND THAT'S WHAT HAPPENED IN
JULY.
THE PRICES WERE 200 AND THE
DSGS, YOU KNOW,
OPTION THREE STARTED TO BECOME
A PART OF THAT.
SO I THINK WE ARE KIND OF
THINKING
THROUGH THAT IN THAT LENS.
BUT, YOU KNOW, REALLY WELCOME
YOUR PUSH
AND CHALLENGE ON CONTINUED
EXPENSES PROGRAMS.
THANK YOU.
LAST QUESTION.
IF YOU'LL INDULGE ME, MR.
CHAIR, JUST TO FOLLOW THROUGH
THE THOUGHT, UM, UH,
HOPE WE CAN LEVERAGE AS MUCH
FEDERAL
FUNDS ON THIS FRONT AS POSSIBLE.
WE KNOW THERE'S THERE'S MONEY
OUT ON DEMAND SIDE SUPPORT
AND AS WELL AS ON THE
TRANSMISSION SIDE, TOO.
AND SO THE MORE WE CAN GET
OUTSIDE THE RATE
BASE AND FIND OTHER SOURCES OF
MONEY.
UM, YOU KNOW, TIME'S TICKING
HERE.
WE'VE GOT A SHORT WINDOW.
WE'VE GOT A COUPLE BIG DEALS
THROUGH THE PIPELINE.
BUT I'D LOVE TO SEE MORE ACTION
ON
THE ENERGY FRONT TO LEVERAGE
ALL THAT.
BUT JUST TURNING TO ISO JUST
FOR YOUR SORT OF ROUNDED OUT
TAKE ON MEETING THESE THESE
RELIABILITY CHALLENGES.
WHAT I DIDN'T SEE IN THE THE
REPORT ON THE PATHWAYS
INITIATIVE WAS JUST A SENSE
OF WHAT,
WHAT YOU ALL ANTICIPATE OR HAVE
MODELED.
UM, I SAW SORT OF, UM,
RETROSPECTIVE NUMBERS ON THE
5.85
BILLION IN GROSS BENEFITS FOR
PARTICIPANTS
SINCE 2014, IN THE IM.
BUT DO YOU HAVE NUMBERS ON SORT
OF
UNDER THIS NEW HYPOTHETICAL
MODEL?
THAT'S BEFORE THE BOARD.
UM, WHAT WE COULD SEE BOTH FROM
A RATE CALIFORNIA
RATEPAYER SAVINGS PERSPECTIVE,
AS WELL AS A SORT OF THIS
RELIABILITY.
UM, UH, YOU KNOW HOW MUCH OF
THIS
COULD ACTUALLY MEET SO WE
DON'T HAVE TO BE TURNING ON
THE OTCS OR RELYING ON THEM?
HOW MUCH OF THAT COULD COME
FROM THIS
NEW ENHANCED DAM OR WHATEVER?
YEAH, THANKS VERY MUCH, SENATOR.
YOU KNOW, THERE'S THERE'S BEEN
A RANGE OF DIFFERENT STUDIES,
OBVIOUSLY, LIKE EVERYTHING IT'S
ASSUMPTION DRIVEN.
IT DEPENDS ON HOW BROAD THE
FOOTPRINT IS.
BUT JUST THIS LAST QUARTER,
THE ENERGY IMBALANCE MARKET
ITSELF
PRODUCED ABOUT $365 MILLION OF
SAVINGS FOR FOR CONSUMERS.
AND WE COULD SEE AT LEAST THAT
IF,
IF PROBABLY CLOSE TO A DOUBLING
OF
THAT ON JUST THE ECONOMIC SIDE.
I THINK THE KEY THING, THOUGH,
THAT I'D LIKE TO EMPHASIZE,
AND WE'VE BEEN FINDING MORE
AND MORE,
IS THAT REALLY THE ABILITY OF
THE OF THE BROADER FOOTPRINT
MARKET TO SUPPORT THE SYSTEM
DURING EXTREME EVENTS?
THE RELIABILITY ELEMENT IS
BECOMING
INCREASINGLY IMPORTANT.
I THINK, AS YOU SEE THE
REDUCTION IN THE NUMBER
OF ENERGY EMERGENCY ALERTS,
THAT'S OUR GOAL.
WE WANT TO KEEP THE SYSTEM CALM.
WE WANT TO HAVE THAT WIDE AREA
VISIBILITY.
WE WANT TO UNDERSTAND NOT WHAT'S
HAPPENING,
NOT ONLY WHAT'S HAPPENING IN
CALIFORNIA,
BUT WHAT'S HAPPENING IN THE
BROADER WEST,
SO THAT ON A DAY AHEAD BASIS,
WE'LL HAVE THE ABILITY
TO MOVE POWER TO WHERE IT'S MOST
NEEDED,
GIVEN THE CAPABILITIES OF THE
TRANSMISSION SYSTEM.
SO I THINK BOTH THE SIGNIFICANT
IMPROVEMENT IN THE ECONOMICS,
BUT PROBABLY EVEN MORE
IMPORTANTLY,
I THINK THE RELIABILITY BENEFITS
ARE GOING TO BE WHERE
THE VALUE PROPOSITION REALLY IS
GOING TO LIE.
I REALLY APPRECIATE THAT.
AND I JUST I HOPE YOU TAKE THE
NEXT STEP.
I THINK YOU'VE PUT A REALLY
GOOD PROPOSAL ON THE TABLE.
I APPRECIATE THE PUBLIC INTEREST
EDITION,
AND I HOPE WE KEEP,
YOU KNOW, GOING FORWARD
DELIBERATELY HERE.
THANK YOU SIR.
THANK YOU.
SENATOR SATO.
I THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND THANK
YOU FOR ALL
THE INFORMATION TODAY AND
KEEPING US
UP TO DATE ON OUR EFFORTS TO
HAVE RELIABLE,
UM, ENERGY TO OUR, OUR CITIZENS.
UH, A COUPLE QUESTIONS REGARDING
THE THE PATHWAYS INITIATIVE.
UM, I'M LOOKING AT YOUR NEXT
STEPS
AND THE JULY AUGUST PUBLIC
MEETINGS.
HOW MANY MEETINGS HAVE WE HAD
SO FAR?
UM, SO SO THE PATHWAYS GROUP
HAS DONE
MULTIPLE STAKEHOLDER MEETINGS.
I BELIEVE TWO, UH, WAS JUST
BASED ON THE WORKSHOPS.
THERE'S A THIRD ONE IN PROCESS,
BUT AS A AS A MATTER OF THEIR
PROCESS,
THEY HAVE BEEN DOING,
UM, I THINK ONE EVERY MONTH,
UH, A PUBLIC,
UM, KIND OF DISCUSSION ON THE
PROGRESS.
IT'S THE PATHWAYS COMMITTEE
DOING THAT.
AND IN TERMS OF KAISER,
I'LL DEFER TO KAISER IN TERMS
OF WHEN
THEY GOT THE STEP ONE AND WHAT
WORKSHOPS WERE DONE THERE.
RIGHT?
YEAH.
USUALLY I GET TO KNOW MORE THAN
THE PUBLIC WHEN WE'RE HAVING
THESE.
AND THIS IS THE FIRST TIME I'VE
EVEN SEEN THIS.
SO I DON'T KNOW WHAT OUR
OUTREACH IS TO
THE PUBLIC AND WHEN THOSE
MEETINGS ARE.
BUT THIS IS SOMETHING IMPORTANT
FOR
PEOPLE TO UNDERSTAND SO THEY
UNDERSTAND WHY WE'RE DOING IT OR
WHY WHY IT NEEDS TO BE DONE.
AND IF IT'S SOMETHING THAT IS
JUST KIND
OF PART OF A BOX TO CHECK OFF.
OH, YEAH, WE DID PUBLIC
MEETINGS,
WE DID THIS, AND NOW WE'RE DOING
THIS.
YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE A LOT OF
PUSHBACK FROM THE PUBLIC
BECAUSE ANYTHING THAT THEY THINK
IS OR IT MIGHT,
UH, RAISE THEIR UH, UH, RATES
RIGHT NOW
OR THEY'RE HYPERSENSITIVE TO IT.
UM, SO ON, UH, ONE OF YOUR
SLIDES, YOU HAD,
UH, THE, THE ISSUE ABOUT, YOU
KNOW,
SOME OF THE ISSUES GOING ON
WITH,
WITH TRANSMISSION RELIABILITY
AND STUFF.
YOU HAD 19 INCIDENTS OF
TRANSMISSION ISSUES.
THAT'S MORE THAN ALL OF
THE YEARS COMBINED BEFORE HERE.
WHAT IS GOING ON WITH OUR
TRANSMISSION ISSUES?
YEAH, I'LL SPEAK TO THAT.
YES, SENATOR.
UM, THANKS FOR ASKING THE
QUESTION.
WE HAVE A SPECIAL CATEGORY OF
OF ALERT
KNOWN AS A TRANSMISSION
EMERGENCY,
WHICH IS HONESTLY, IT SOUNDS
A LITTLE BIT
MORE EXTREME THAN WHAT IT REALLY
IS.
IT ACTUALLY TYPICALLY REFERS TO
A VERY DISCRETE SET OF EVENTS
IN A PARTICULAR PORTION OF
THE GRID WHERE DUE TO FIRE,
WHICH HAS BEEN THE CASE THIS
SUMMER,
THERE IS STRESS ON THE LOCAL
TRANSMISSION
SYSTEM THAT REQUIRES A CHANGE
IN GENERATION PATTERNS,
AND TYPICALLY IT ALLOWS THE
ABILITY OF THE UTILITY
THAT'S AFFECTED IN THE AREA
TO HAVE
ITS POWER SIDE AND ITS
TRANSMISSION SIDE
COORDINATE IN EXTRAORDINARY
FASHION.
SO BY THE DECLARATION OF THE
TRANSMISSION EMERGENCY,
IT OPENS UP ACCESS TO SOME
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES.
IT ALLOWS FOR ENHANCED
COMMUNICATION.
AND THEN WE'RE ABLE TO BRING
THAT TO RESOLUTION.
WE HAVE BEEN OPERATING THAT IN
PARTICULARLY UP IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA QUITE A NUMBER OF
DAYS THIS SUMMER.
WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO PREVENT ANY
BROADER DISTURBANCES,
BUT IT CERTAINLY IS A VERY
DIFFERENT CATEGORY
OF EVENT THAN AN ENERGY
EMERGENCY ALERT,
WHICH REFERS TO A BROADER
RELIABILITY
ISSUE FOR THE BROADER GRID.
RIGHT.
SO JUST THIS LAST MONTH, AT THE
END OF JUNE,
BEGINNING OF JULY, EL DORADO
HILLS,
UH, TWO DAYS IN A ROW,
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE WITHOUT
POWER, FIVE HOURS.
IT'S 105 DEGREES.
AND AND SO THAT'S I THINK THOSE
ARE
THE THINGS THAT THE PUBLIC
WORRIES ABOUT.
AND, AND SO WHEN WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT TRANSMISSION AND YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT WILDFIRES AND
TRANSMISSION LINES,
UM, YOU KNOW, THAT'S ONE OF OUR
CONCERNS.
ALSO, I LOOK AT THIS WHOLE
PROCESS,
THIS WHOLE EFFORT AND THE WHOLE,
YOU KNOW,
EFFORT TO ADDRESS CLIMATE CHANGE
AND GO 100% RENEWABLE ENERGY
AND ALL OF THAT AS TRYING TO
GET FROM POINT A TO POINT B.
>> HERE TO HAVE AN OPEN
CONVERSATION.
LOVE TO ANSWER QUESTIONS.
THAT'S RIGHT.
AND THE FASTEST WAY ON THE ROAD
TO GET FROM POINT
A TO POINT B IS TO JUMP IN YOUR
TESLA MODEL
S AND GET ON A STRAIGHT ROAD
THAT
HAS NO BUMPS AND NO CURVES,
AND GO 120 MILES AN HOUR.
AND SOMETIMES I FEEL LIKE WE'RE
TRYING TO DO THAT.
BUT THE PROBLEM IS WE'RE ON
A CURVY
ROAD WITH A BUNCH OF BUMPS.
WE HAVE A CURVY ROAD WITH A
BUNCH OF POTHOLES IN IT,
AND THOSE POTHOLES ARE.
AND THE CURVES ARE STUFF THAT
WE DON'T CONTROL,
WHETHER, UM,
WHETHER OR NOT WE MEET OUR GOAL
IN 2045 OR WHATEVER IT IS.
UH, THE WEATHER IS STILL GOING
TO BE AN ISSUE.
UM, IT'S NOT GOING TO CHANGE.
EVEN WHEN WE HIT OUR GOALS,
IT IS NOT GOING TO CHANGE.
1% IS NOT GOING TO CHANGE THE
WORLD'S WEATHER.
UM, THE NATURAL DISASTERS,
BECAUSE THAT'S NOT JUST WEATHER
RELATED.
THOSE ARE ALSO EARTHQUAKES.
WE ARE EARTHQUAKE PRONE OUT
HERE.
THAT CAN SET US BACK.
UH, OUR INFRASTRUCTURE
DEVELOPMENT PROBLEMS.
THAT'S ANOTHER CURVE THAT MAKES
US SLOW DOWN.
UM, AND THOSE SUPPLY CHAINS AND
THINGS LIKE THAT.
UM, A BIG ONE.
IT'S REALLY BIG RIGHT NOW.
IS THE COST BORNE BY CONSUMERS
TO TRY TO DO ALL THIS,
GOING 120 MILES AN HOUR,
TRYING TO GET FROM POINT A TO
POINT B BEFORE
IT'S ACTUALLY PRACTICAL FOR US
TO GET THERE.
THE PRACTICAL THE PROBLEM WITH
THAT IS
AS CONSUMERS BECOME MORE AND
MORE
UNABLE TO KEEP UP WITH THE
COSTS,
THEY START LEAVING, LEAVING OUR
STATE.
AND AND WE'RE HEADING INTO SOME
ECONOMIC ISSUES
NOW THAT ARE STARTING TO REFLECT
THAT.
AND THE LAST PART OF ONE OF
THE OTHER CURVES IS OUR BUDGET.
OBVIOUSLY, OUR BUDGET IS NOT
WHAT WE WISHED
IT COULD BE TO BE ABLE TO
ADDRESS
ALL THESE PROBLEMS SO WE COULD
GO 100 MILES
AN HOUR DOWN THAT STRAIGHT ROAD.
AND SO, YOU KNOW, I THINK IN
TERMS OF BEING
ABLE TO ACCOMPLISH ALL OF THESE
SET GOALS,
WE'RE WE'RE STRUGGLING WITH
THAT.
AND I THINK WE'RE GOING TO
CONTINUE TO STRUGGLE.
AND THAT'S WHAT WE NEED TO TO BE
ABLE TO PLAN FOR.
WE NEED TO WE NEED NUMBER ONE
TO BE RELIABLE,
TO KEEP OUR PUBLIC SAFE.
AND PART OF THAT MEANS GOING
AT A PACE THAT ALLOWS US TO
BURY TRANSMISSION LINES WHERE
THEY NEED TO BE BURIED,
UM, AND NOT MAKE EXCUSES FOR
WHY THEY
SHOULD BE OKAY OVER A BRUSH
AREA.
THEY'RE NOT.
WE HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
UNDERSTAND
THAT THAT MAKES A DIFFERENCE.
YOU'VE SAID IT THREE TIMES IN
THIS HEARING.
THAT TRANSMISSION LINES AND
FIRES DON'T WORK.
AND YET WE CONTINUE TO GO DOWN
THAT SAME PATH.
WHY?
BECAUSE IT'S BETTER TO DO IT
FASTER
THAN IT IS TO DO IT RIGHT.
AND THAT'S WHAT I WANT TO MAKE
SURE
THAT WE'RE DOING IT RIGHT.
AND SO SOME OF THESE EFFORTS
ARE IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION.
YOU GUYS ARE DOING A PHENOMENAL
JOB.
UM, ENSURING THAT YOU'RE WORKING
WITH
THE THE TOOLS THAT YOU HAVE TO
TO ENSURE
THAT WE'RE AS SAFE AS WE CAN BE
AND WE'RE AS RELIABLE AS WE
CAN BE.
BUT THE FASTER WE GO THROUGH
THOSE CURVES,
THE MORE CHANCES WE ARE GOING
TO GET
THAT WE WILL RUN OFF THE ROAD.
AND THAT, AND ONE OF ANY ONE OF
THESE THINGS
CAN BE THE TRIGGER FOR THAT
HAPPENING.
AND SO THOSE ARE MY CONCERNS.
AND LIKE I SAID, I APPRECIATE
WHAT YOU
DO EVERY DAY TO KEEP US POWERED
UP.
AND SO DO THE CONSTITUENTS OUT
THERE.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, SENATOR DODD.
YEAH.
FIRST OF ALL, APPRECIATE YOU
BEING HERE TODAY.
UH, I'M SORRY I WASN'T ABLE
TO BE
IN THE ROOM THE ENTIRE TIME,
BUT I WAS WATCHING A LITTLE IN
MY OFFICE IN BETWEEN MEETINGS.
UH, OBVIOUSLY, WE HAVE
RELIABILITY ISSUES.
TRANSMISSION ISSUES.
WE GOT RATE RELIEF ISSUES.
AND WE'RE TRYING TO DO THIS
ALL IN
THE CONTEXT OF A ZERO CARBON
FUTURE.
UH, I DON'T NEED TO GIVE
PLATITUDES TO ANY OF YOU,
LET ALONE ALL FOUR OF YOU,
IN TERMS OF THE JOB THAT YOU'VE
DONE.
I'M LEAVING HERE IN 3 OR 4
MONTHS,
AND I JUST DO HAVE TO TELL YOU.
AND I THINK THAT SENATOR SARTO
IS RIGHT.
WE HAVE A LOT OF STRUGGLES.
THERE'S A LOT OF ISSUES.
AND TO USE THE ANALOGY THAT OUR
GOOD CHAIRMAN USED
EARLIER ABOUT FLYING THIS PLANE
WHILE WE'RE
RE-ENGINEERING IT AND AND DOING
ALL THE WORK,
I CAN TELL YOU, AS I AM LEAVING
THE LEGISLATURE,
I AM CONFIDENT IN THE QUALITY
OF THE PEOPLE
THAT ARE SITTING IN FRONT OF ME
AND THE JOB THAT YOU'RE TRYING
TO DO EVERY
SINGLE DAY AND MAKING THIS WORK,
NOT ONLY NOT FOR THE
LEGISLATURE,
FOR THE PEOPLE THAT WE ALL
SERVE.
AND WHILE IT'S NOT PERFECT,
JUST KNOW THAT THERE ARE PEOPLE
THAT ARE NOTICING THE REALLY
GREAT WORK THAT'S
COMING OUT OF THIS STATE BECAUSE
OF THE FOUR OF YOU
AND THE PEOPLE THAT YOU WORK
WITH EVERY SINGLE DAY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU.
UM, I HAVE SOME COMMENTS,
BUT I WAS GOING TO SEE IF YOUR
SCHEDULE ALLOWS YOU TO FIRST
HEAR ORAL COMMUNICATIONS.
WE WANT TO HEAR FROM THE PUBLIC
FIRST.
SO IF THERE ARE MEMBERS HERE IN
THIS ROOM WHO HAVE COMMENTS,
WE ASK YOU TO FORM A LINE AND
WE'LL
GIVE YOU ONE MINUTE EACH.
AND.
I THINK MR..
WHICH IS THE FIRST ONE UP.
>> THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS.
SCOTT WETCH, ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA
COALITION OF UTILITY
EMPLOYEES AND THE STATE
ASSOCIATION
OF ELECTRICAL WORKERS.
I'M GOING TO FOCUS ON THE
PATHWAYS PROCESS.
AS YOU ALL KNOW, WE'VE BEEN THE
PROVERBIAL
FLY IN THE OINTMENT AND OPPOSED
ALL THREE OF THE PRIOR
LEGISLATIVE
ATTEMPTS AT REGIONALIZATION.
THOSE PROPOSALS WOULD HAVE
TRANSFORMED
THE CAISO ITSELF INTO AN RTO.
IN CONTRAST, THE PATHWAYS
INITIATIVE WOULD
PRESERVE THE KAISO AND ITS
BALANCING
AUTHORITY AND OTHER FUNCTIONS
EXCEPT
FOR CONTROL OVER THE ENERGY
MARKETS.
THE IBEW IS A MEMBER OF
THE PATHWAYS LAUNCH COMMITTEE.
WE ARE PLEASED WITH THE PROGRESS
OF THE LAUNCH
COMMITTEE HAS MADE IN THE PAST
YEAR.
WE REMAIN OPTIMISTIC THAT
THE LAUNCH COMMITTEE WILL BE
ABLE TO MAKE A RECOMMENDATION
TO CREATE A NEW REGIONAL
ORGANIZATION AND TRANSFER
OVERSIGHT
OF THE ENERGY MARKETS
FROM THE CAISO TO THE NEW
REGIONAL ORGANIZATION.
THIS STEP WILL ENABLE MANY MORE
UTILITIES AROUND
THE WEST TO JOIN THE DAY AHEAD
MARKET.
I WANT TO EMPHASIZE THAT WE
FORESEE THAT
THE PROPOSAL WOULD NOT AFFECT
CALIFORNIA,
CALIFORNIA'S OR ANY OTHER
STATE'S
ABILITY TO PROTECT ITS POLICIES,
SUCH AS RENEWABLE PORTFOLIO
STANDARDS,
TRANSMISSION PLANNING,
COST ALLOCATION OR GHG
REDUCTION.
IT COULD EVEN ENHANCE OUR
ABILITY TO DECARBONIZE
AT LOWER COSTS BY ALLOWING US
TO USE SOLAR,
WIND AND HYDRO RESOURCES MORE
EFFICIENTLY.
I ALSO JUST WANT TO EMPHASIZE
THAT THE PATHWAYS PROPOSAL
BEING DEVELOPED WOULD PRESERVE
CALIFORNIA JOBS,
UNLIKE PREVIOUS REGIONALIZATION
PROPOSALS.
WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
THE LEGISLATURE
NEXT YEAR TO ENACT THAT
LEGISLATION,
AND THAT WOULD ALLOW CALIFORNIA
UTILITIES TO PARTICIPATE
IN A DAY AHEAD MARKET WITH A
WIDER FOOTPRINT.
WELL, THANK YOU FOR THE HEARING
TODAY
AND FOR ALL THE PARTICIPANTS.
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS?
>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH, MR.
CHAIRMAN.
MY NAME IS DAN JACOBSON TODAY
ADVOCATING ON BEHALF
OF THE CLEAN ENERGY BUYERS
ASSOCIATION.
I JUST WANT TO THANK THE PANEL
VERY MUCH FOR THEIR HARD
WORK AND PARTICULARLY FOCUS ON
RESOURCE ADEQUACY,
WHICH WE THINK IS A CRITICAL
PIECE TO BOTH
BEING ABLE TO HELP KEEP THE
RATES DOWN,
BUT ALSO BE ABLE TO MOVE US
TOWARD MORE CLEAN ENERGY,
THE LOSS OF LOAD,
AND THE 1 IN 10 EXPECTATION
WE THINK IS, IS CRITICAL.
UM, THIS COMMITTEE HAS MOVED
OUT BILLS THAT
WOULD THAT WOULD HELP US MOVE
TOWARD THAT,
AND WE WOULD ENCOURAGE US TO
CONTINUE
TO MOVE IN THAT DIRECTION.
SO THANK YOU ALL VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU.
>> THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIR.
AND MEMBERS.
MEGAN LOPER, ON BEHALF OF
WESTERN FREEDOM,
WHICH IS A COALITION
REPRESENTING LARGE ENERGY
USERS ACROSS THE WEST WHO ARE
INTERESTED IN CLEAN,
AFFORDABLE AND RELIABLE ENERGY,
AND WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE
PANELISTS
AND THE COMMITTEE FOR THE
CONTINUED
FOCUS ON RELIABILITY AND
AFFORDABILITY
AND HOW WE REACH OUR GOALS.
I'M KATHLEEN STACKS, WHO'S THE
EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF WESTERN FREEDOM,
HAS BEEN HONORED TO SERVE AS
ONE OF
THE PATHWAYS CO-CHAIRS AND HAS
FELT THAT IT
HAS PROVIDED A GREAT OPPORTUNITY
FOR COLLABORATION
AND REALLY GOOD DISCUSSION,
NOT ONLY WITH MANY OF OUR
CALIFORNIA
BASED STAKEHOLDERS,
BUT OTHER PARTNERS ACROSS THE
WEST.
AND WE DO LOOK FORWARD, AS YOU
HEARD FROM MR.
WELCH, TO THOSE CONTINUED
DISCUSSIONS
AND HOPE THAT THIS PROCESS WILL
ALLOW US
TO COME BACK TO THE LEGISLATURE
BETTER
INFORMED AND WITH MORE CONSENSUS
ABOUT
WHAT POLICY PROPOSALS THE
LEGISLATURE SHOULD
CONTINUE TO CONSIDER IN THE
FUTURE
TO HELP US REACH OUR
AFFORDABILITY,
RELIABILITY AND CLEAN ENERGY
GOALS.
SO WITH THAT, THANK YOU FOR THE
CONTINUED
FOCUS ON THESE ISSUES,
AND WE APPRECIATE THE WORK OF
THE PANELISTS
AND YOUR COMMITTEE STAFF AND
ALL OF YOU.
THANK YOU.
MR.
COOK, COME ON UP.
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS.
>> GREG COOK, REPRESENTING
NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA POWER AGENCY.
I WOULD LIKE TO PURSUE THE
QUESTIONING
THAT SENATOR STERN
RAISED WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
WATER RESOURCES,
SPECIFICALLY THE USE OF EXISTING
FUNDS OR AVAILABLE
FUNDS FOR THE RETROFIT OF
EXISTING FACILITIES
TO MAKE THEM MORE EFFICIENT AND
PROVIDE GREATER
RESOURCES AS WE GO INTO THE
FUTURE.
SPECIFICALLY, THE NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA POWER
AGENCY OPERATES THE LODI ENERGY
CENTER.
THE LARGEST INVESTOR IN THE LODI
ENERGY CENTER
IS THE DEPARTMENT OF WATER
RESOURCES.
THEY OWN 38% OF THE FACILITY.
NCPA HAS A PROPOSAL TO IMPROVE
THE EFFICIENCY
OF THAT OPERATION BY 25%.
THE ENERGY COMMISSION HAS SEEN
THE VALUE OF THAT,
AND SO THEY HAVE CONTRIBUTED
$7 MILLION
TO THE COST OF THAT IMPROVEMENT.
THE DEPARTMENT OF WATER
RESOURCES HAS SENT SIGNALS
THAT THEY ARE NOT GOING TO
PARTICIPATE IN,
IN FUNDING AND EXPANDING THAT
FACILITIES
RESOURCE THEY UTILIZE.
THEY ARE, AS I UNDERSTAND IT,
THAT THEY USE THE PASSAGE OF
SENATE BILL
1020 A COUPLE OF YEARS AGO AS
THE RATIONALE FOR HOW THEY WHY
THEY
CANNOT PARTICIPATE IN THIS
EXTRAORDINARILY
IMPORTANT EXPANSION OF
AN EXISTING ASSET TO INCREASE
THE EFFICIENCY
OF THAT FACILITY BY 25%.
I DON'T UNDERSTAND THE REASON
WHY,
AND I WOULD LIKE THE COMMITTEE
TO PURSUE THAT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU.
MR.
CHAIRMAN.
>> MEMBERS JOHN WHITE WITH THE
CLEAN POWER CAMPAIGN,
THANK YOU FOR THIS EXCELLENT
HEARING
AND FOR THE TESTIMONY
FOR US TO KEEP TRACK OF ALL
THESE MOVING TARGETS.
I WANT TO RETURN TO THE PENDING
CENTRAL
PROCUREMENT PROPOSAL AT THE PUC.
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT'S MISSING
FROM THAT
PROPOSAL THAT WAS ORIGINALLY
INTENDED BY
THE LEGISLATURE WITH THE PASSAGE
OF AB 1373,
IS IMPERIAL VALLEY GEOTHERMAL
BEING PROCURED,
EVEN THOUGH THE MID-TERM
RELIABILITY PROCUREMENT
DIRECTED THE UTILITIES TO BUY
GEOTHERMAL,
THE LOAD SERVING ENTITIES
HAVEN'T
SIGNED POWER PURCHASE
AGREEMENTS.
SO THE GEOTHERMAL WE'RE TRYING
TO DEVELOP
DOWN IN IMPERIAL FOR THE ABILITY
ALSO TO DEVELOP THE LITHIUM
INDUSTRY
IS GOING TO BE DELAYED.
SO WE REALLY HOPE THE COMMISSION
WILL TAKE A CLOSER
LOOK AT THE VALUE OF THE
CONVENTIONAL GEOTHERMAL,
AND INCLUDE THAT IN THE
PROCUREMENT BY DWR.
THANK YOU.
ANY ADDITIONAL PARTICIPANTS
HERE IN
THE ROOM WHO WANT TO ADD COMMENT
TESTIMONY?
ALL RIGHT.
SEEING NONE.
UM, I TOO WANT TO THANK OUR
PANELISTS.
UH, YOU'VE DONE A YEOMAN'S JOB
WITH
WHAT YOU HAVE TO WORK WITH,
AND I'M JUST GOING TO BE HONEST.
YOU'RE DOING IT WITH YOUR ARMS
TIED BEHIND YOUR BACK.
AND MUCH OF THE REASON WHY IT'S
BECAUSE
OF SOME OF THE ASPIRATIONAL
POLICIES THAT WE HAVE PASSED AS
A LEGISLATURE.
AND I'M JUST GOING TO BE REAL
ABOUT THAT.
AS SOMEONE WHO IS IN MY 14TH
YEAR IN THE LEGISLATURE AND
IF HAVE CHAIRED ENERGY ON BOTH
THE ASSEMBLY AND THE ASSEMBLY,
UM, I HAVE NO DOUBT THAT MUCH
OF WHAT
WE PASSED HAS GOOD INTENTIONS.
BUT AS THE OLD FOLKS USED TO
TELL ME,
THE ROAD TO HELL IS PAVED EN
PAVED WITH GOOD INTENTIONS,
AND WE FIND OURSELVES HERE TODAY
WITH THESE CHALLENGES BECAUSE
OUR LEGISLATION HAS BEEN MORE
ASPIRATIONAL THAN PRACTICAL.
AND I WOULD WHEN I LOOK AT THE
TITLE OF THIS HEARING
OF ELECTRIC RELIABILITY TOWARD
ZERO EMISSIONS,
WE'RE FOCUSING ON INTERMITTENT
INTERMITTENT RESOURCES INSTEAD
OF DISPATCHABLE RESOURCES,
BASELOAD RESOURCES.
AND WHEN WE TALK ABOUT ZERO
EMISSION,
WE'RE FOCUSING ON NOT THE TWO
CLEANEST
SOURCES OF ZERO EMISSION ENERGY.
AND THAT'S NUCLEAR AND HYDRO.
SO AT SOME POINT, WE NEED TO
START
HAVING REAL ADULT CONVERSATIONS
ABOUT WHAT OUR GOALS AND
OBJECTIVES ARE.
IF IT'S ABOUT ZERO EMISSIONS,
THEN WE NEED TO TALK ABOUT THE
CLEANEST SOURCE.
YOU TALK TO ANY ELECTRICAL
ENGINEER
IN THE WORLD AND THEY'LL TELL
YOU,
AS YOU GUYS WILL ATTEST TO,
HYDRO AND NUCLEAR ARE THE
CLEANEST SOURCES WE HAVE.
SO AND WE TALK ABOUT
RELIABILITY,
BASELOAD, DISPATCHABLE
RESOURCES.
IT'S WHERE WE HAVE REAL
RELIABILITY,
NOT ON BATTERIES, WIND AND
SOLAR.
AND WE NEED TO EXPAND UPON THAT.
AND WE NEED TO HAVE THOSE
CONVERSATIONS.
AND THAT'S WHERE I THINK WE LOSE
THE PUBLIC.
AND AGAIN, AND AS WE SAY, WE
DRIVE UP COSTS.
AS MY COLLEAGUE STATED,
IF WE'RE REALLY TALKING ABOUT
CONSUMERS,
CONSUMERS ARE FEELING THIS AND
WE NEED TO BE
MORE PRACTICAL IN WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO DO,
LEGISLATION THAT WE CAN
IMPLEMENT THAT REALLY
ACHIEVES THE GOALS OF A CLEANER
ENVIRONMENT,
BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY, A
RELIABILITY.
AND OUR WANTS.
WE WOULDN'T HAVE MADE OUR
CLIMATE
GOALS TWO YEARS AGO.
OUR WORLD CLIMATE GOALS
IF IT WASN'T FOR NATURAL GAS.
BUT NOBODY WANTS TO HAVE THAT
CONVERSATION.
AND SO THAT'S MY DESIRE AS I
LEAVE THE LEGISLATURE,
THAT WE HAVE POLICY MORE ROOTED
IN.
I WANT TO SEE REALITY AND
IMPLEMENTATION,
AND WE NEED TO HEAR FROM THE
AGENCIES,
AND WE NEED TO HEAR MORE
PUSHBACK IF WE'RE MOVING IN
A DIRECTION THAT MAKES IT HARDER
FOR YOU TO DO YOUR JOB.
SO THAT'S WHERE I AM ON THAT.
SO I DON'T KNOW IF ANY MORE
COMMENTS
ABOUT MY COLLEAGUE'S LAST WORD.
ALL RIGHT.
WELL, AGAIN, I WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TESTIMONY.
I THANK YOU FOR THE WORK THAT
YOU'RE
DOING ON A DAILY BASIS.
IT'S TRULY NEEDED.
AND AS OUR COLLEAGUE STATED,
WE'RE CREATING SOME OF THOSE
POTHOLES.
AND I WANT TO BE ABLE TO HELP
YOU
GUYS IMPLEMENT THIS AND MAKE IT
WORK FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS AND
FOR
THE ENVIRONMENT AS A WHOLE.
SO, UH, FOR ANY INDIVIDUAL THAT
DIDN'T
GET A CHANCE TO ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE,
WE ASK THAT YOU SUBMIT YOUR
QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS IN WRITING
WOULD BE MORE THAN HAPPY TO LOOK
AT THEM AND CONSIDERATION.
AND I WANT TO THANK THE STAFF,
UH,
AND INDIVIDUALS WHO CALLED.
AND WE THANK EVERYONE FOR YOUR
PATIENCE AND YOUR COOPERATION
TODAY AND PARTICIPATING IN THIS
HEARING.
WE'VE CONCLUDED OUR AGENDA,
AND THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON
ENERGY,
UTILITIES AND COMMUNICATIONS IS
NOW ADJOURNED.
THANK YOU.